wow what a wild night last night thank
you all for hanging out with us we were
in Iowa got back at around 3:40 a.m. I
am exhausted we got big news tonight the
GOP debates in New Hampshire have been
canceled Nikki Haley is refusing to
debate unless Donald Trump is there
Ronda Santa says he will debate two
empty podiums and they were like yeah
okay no Ron thanks for the offer but uh
Nikki Haley did the meme and so uh this
is one of the funniest things she's ever
done she basically declares or she
literally declares that the result on
Iowa prove it's now a two-person race
but she came in third place so I guess
she's uh in some way conceding to Ronda
santis I I guess but I I think the
reality here is the establishment play
is that the GOP Primary is the actual
election Nikki Haley is a Democrat she
is funded by Democrats Democrats are
voting for her and I think they're
hoping that in places like New York City
and California and Illinois when they
have their Republican primaries
Democrats show out in force for Nikki
Haley and then it doesn't matter if Joe
Biden is running for the Democratic
ticket because if it's Biden versus
Haley you get a Democrat either way so
we'll talk about that but the ramaswami
announced last night that he was
dropping out of the race and uh I think
we kind of realized it because you know
we we really like he is a great guy with
all due respect um he did cancel on us
while we had uh scheduled him for the
show that Monday and I think it's fairly
obvious why when the results came in
they were a lot they were a lot worse
than I think the v's campaign expected
and so while he was supposed to join us
here on Tim castl he ended up not
showing up and I think we all kind of
realized what was uh what was about to
happen but he did then endorse Donald
Trump he appeared in New Hampshire today
with Donald Trump and after speaking the
crowd began chanting VP over and over
over again people are really excited for
the prospect but we will see Donald
Trump basically said they're going to be
working with him in some capacity but
who knows what that really means we'll
talk a lot about that and uh we'll talk
about the uh the primary process and
where we're going lot of uh lot of lot
of uh this stuff going on today with GOP
Primary related stuff but there is a big
story that I think we may get into a
report from The Daily Mail that China
has created a new they've they've gain
of function researched a new virus that
has a 100% kill rate in the mice that
infected so we're glad to hear that
especially we're talking about World War
III and all that stuff so great all
right everybody if you uh before we get
started head over to cast brew.com and
buy our coffee this show is sponsored by
cast Brew Coffee it is our company we
sponsor ourselves and we got really
really great coffee it's the best at
least that's what I've been told now in
my personal opinion I actually do think
it is the best Appalachia nights is
everyone's favorite if you want to
support the show and you would like a
coffee go to casper.com purchase our
products because it helps support the
work we do and we do have a new blend
out Alex Stein's prime time grind two
times caffeine drink responsibly we are
uh currently running commercials of Alex
Stein trying to free base coffee and
then he figures out how to finally drink
coffee don't don't do that but you can
drink the coffee it's available at
casper.com and join the Casper coffee
Club but also head over to
timcast.net based records They also help
sponsor the show and make it all
possible so we're really really grateful
to the the guys over at based records at
B and um I just want to say we got plans
for a big event coming up in March we
want to travel more to do on the Ground
events at various primaries and
political rallies and debates we're
planning the RNC we do not make money
doing that I'll put it this way we make
money but we like it costs more money
than we make right we're able to do that
if you guys become members it is
extremely extremely difficult so that
being said Well normally as as a member
you will watch the members only show
Monday through Thursday at uh 10: p.m.
there will not be one tonight because
I'm on the verge of collapse from not
having slept after flying back but we're
here for you guys to keep doing the work
and doing the show so there won't be a
members only show tonight but you also
get access to the Discord server we can
hang out with like-minded individuals we
have a couple documentaries that are up
we're working on more documentaries we
have a bunch of members only content on
timcast.net go to the uh uh the the
primaries and uh interview these
candidates and I want to say as much as
people are cheering for vivik ramaswami
we were able to do a town hall with him
last week Wednesday and it was a
smashing success on YouTube it has
nearly 1 million views the podcast has a
a couple hundred thousand so uh it's all
thanks to you guys as members so smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and everything else is Adam Weiss Tim
thanks for having me I can't believe
you're doing the show after a brutal
week in Iowa and uh with no sleep but
thanks for having me and I'm Madam from
New York I run a Communications PR firm
and I'm a contributor RAV real America's
voice news catch me there every week
right on and of course uh uh we have
Hannah Clair hanging out oh hey you guys
know that uh well first I'm Hanah Clair
brimo I'm a writer for sr.com if Tim
collapses this immediately becomes brim
cast it's like a hostile takeover staged
by me personally I'm really excited
because Libby emons is here hey Hannah
CLA hey Adam Tim thanks for having me on
tonight I'm Libby Emmons with the post
millennial glad to be here well yeah if
you want to do a members only I'll go to
bed and you can you can do a brim cast
after the show I don't even know what I
would talk about solo alone and brim
cast no I could if you wanted me too but
we'll see depend same without you here
Tim I'm tired uh but Libby is here she's
Ian I'm Ian yeah feeling you know we do
these late shows when we fly in I I go I
get to bed at like we get back at 3:30
I'm I'm asleep by like 3:40 because we
got to bring our bags in it snowed four
to like four or five Ines it was very
snowy last night so uh the car that
picked us up holy crap it's so brutal we
could not actually drive from the
airport we almost we couldn't land at
the airport where our car was because of
the snow so we had to land at a
different airport like 40 mil away then
we had to have a car come and pick us up
which they didn't know where to go then
they had to drive in unplowed 4 in in a
Honda Civic we did have some SUVs but
they're it's all unplowed so everyone's
driving we we we drove 20 miles an hour
when we tried to speed up we were
slipping and I'm just like oh this is so
brutal finally get home couldn't go up
the driveway our driveway is about 1,000
ft long it's a long winding middle of
the middle of nor path and so we had to
walk up carrying all the bags and then I
finally get to bed I wake up at 7:00 I
get back to work so uh you know welcome
to work well I wasn't I wasn't up that
late I was up until I guess about 12
12:30 working and filing stories on last
night's adventures in Iowa um but I when
I woke up at 7 I went back to bed I was
like I'm NOP I woke up about to work and
then I was excited to try snowboarding
uh cuz we have finally have snow but
there's no Bas so it just sinks into the
grass no yeah but it is what it is and
then I basically just slept a little bit
and then still had to work but uh we're
here so just pressing the buttons yo I
am uh good to be back and out of the
vortex polar vortex Death Storm we were
in but let's jump to the news ladies and
gentlemen we got this from The New York
Times ABC News cancels GOP debate after
Haley demands Trump AER two Nikki haly
said she would not agree to more debates
unless Donald Trump on stage with her
another debate on CNN was in doubt
before the New Hampshire primary next
week I I just I think it's funny there's
no primary no like this this is not a
primary okay this is something weird
Nikki Haley is not even going to debate
Ronda Sanz why are either of them
running after Trump won with a historic
blowout landslide in Iowa it was a
landslide was 30 points that's the
biggest ever I think the the other the
past record was 12 12% mhm yet Trump's
going to win everybody's wasting their
time however what do we get from what
was it I think MSNBC said I think it was
Joy Reed she's like you know Iowa is all
white Christians so they're of course
going to swing for Trump I think they're
laying out their plan for Nikki Haley
she is Hillary Clinton she is this is
the election the primary is the general
the general is meaningless we were
speculating for a long time about how
they're going to get rid of Joe Biden
and I'll say we were correct Joe Biden
is not their nominee Nikki Haley is the
election is happening right now and when
the primaries go to California Illinois
and New York all of these Urban Liberals
are going to show up as Republicans to
vote for Nikki haly yeah well a lot of
Democrats have been giving money to
Nikki haly and we've seen that we've
seen Nikki haly donors bragging
essentially about how Nikki Haley gets
all of this Democrat money and they're
all really happy about it and also you
had Joy Reed um who yeah we like my
social media team last night was
checking out Joy Reed as well and she
was she was saying that Joy Reed lost
because of racism so they're L because
of racism yeah yeah she's brown lady
apparently so they're already embracing
her with their stupid ethos well I I got
a question real quick just uh does Nikki
Haley appear on the ballots as nimada or
Nikki question Nikki is Nikki
yeah I think one of the interesting
things oh go ahead I said like a few
months ago I said to a small I said why
don't you host the debate they said the
GOP wants like a million bucks I said
what is this a money-making scheme so
they want to they the GOP the national
compan wants to take a ton of money from
the outlets then they want the donors to
pay they invite all the donors to sit
and so I feel like this whole thing's
just a money-making schem me yeah that's
all basically is this is their biggest
money generating time period I would
assume an election year the the problem
is that basically the system they have
built doesn't work in this case I mean I
was watching CBS last night when they
were doing all of the election coverage
and they immediately went into can you
believe that despite all these
self-inflicted wounds that Trump has
incurred you know skipping the debate he
is still managing to win which by the
way was completely predicted I mean they
they do not want him to be the nominee
so badly but it's just at this point
impossible to deny instead of adapting
to the current reality they're trying to
say he is he is unpredictable and we
don't know how this would happen the
only person that shocked us was VC he I
mean he rose from zero to eight right he
was a wonder he amazing spokesperson but
if we all sat here a year ago the result
would have been the same it's like we
wasted a year and we gave aund and
something
you could have done so much with that
money well I I will say I mean I don't
know where Nikki is NE necessarily
spending all of her money but if any of
it is going to Republicans is kind of
funny to hear that Democrats are giving
money to Republicans for Republican
causes I mean she okay she has spent a
ton of money but it was specifically in
Iowa and then in New Hampshire she
hasn't spent very much Nationwide I'll
pull the the numbers in a second from
the ad impact report but you know she
was trying really hard to have an early
Victory with Iowa she didn't succeed in
fact she didn't even win the race for
second place uh despite what she said
this is now what did she say this is now
this clearly a two-person race Now sort
of like I don't think you understand
well she thinks it's a two person race
between her and Biden right ah but
probably not considering she didn't even
make it to Second I just I got I got to
play this clip for you guys okay can we
pull this we can pull this one up I'd
like you to listen to
this I can safely say tonight IA made
this Republican primary a twers race I
despise this woman but this is like this
is like an episode of vep because as
she's saying this at the bottom of the
screen it shows Trump and DeSantis in
the top two positions and not her yeah
95% in it's like it's almost like Curb
Your Enthusiasm or vep she's just so
oblivious to the fact that she lost
she's the meme of the guy cheering and
spraying the champagne and biting the
the metal and then he's in third place
and it's like you lost lady somewhere
along the line we started giving out
trophies to second place to third place
to make kids feel good in high school
and Elementary School this is this is
like Nikki giving herself a trophy after
she lost to be to be fair to be fair we
do give first second and third place
because in the Olympics you've got
thousands or millions of people but when
the race is literally four people you
don't get a medal for coming in bottom
50% technically it was five because as
we as I found out today ASA Hutchin was
in fact there he was yeah he got 191
votes and then said I'm out I'm his
quote was I am driving back to Arkansas
did you see though there was a guy who
yeah there wasow well he was running a
presidential campaign even though none
of us realized it I feel bad for him did
you see there was a someone went up to D
santis the other day and gave him a
participation trophy I did see that it
was a nice little viral clip it was cute
it's very nice of them wasn't it yeah
cuz I mean that's really all he's going
to get in the end the the thing about he
burned down his career for what for what
and you know the thing the thing that
drives me nuts is that that I feel like
he could have been a good candidate and
he had such a poor team his team is
spiteful and mean and exclusionary and
you know like they don't they don't do
anything good for him when we say that V
is running the campaign we hope to Ron
to S D santis wood you look now at VI
hugging Donald Trump on stage at a rally
while they chant VP and it's like I'm
just imagining Ron is outside at the
window looking in with like a single
tear rolling down his cheek like that
could be me and it's cold the
wind
VI embraced his youth he embraced the
fact that he was uh you know doing all
kinds of podcasts he he took the New
Media route there were a lot of things
that I think desantis's team maybe
failed to advise him correctly on and
you know presenting this young fresh
image was one of them it seemed to me
like he sort of became more buttoned up
and closed off as his campaign
progressed and it's difficult to dig
opportunities right whereas V has really
presented himself in this beautiful open
communicative light which I think is
what people want especially from Young
candidates I mean they are similar ages
they have similar age children and yet
they they seem very different seem so
different there was such a cool thing
the other day it was like a it was a
compar contrast you had how VI hand
handled a Heckler and how DeSantis
handled a Heckler and Viv was like right
this was amazing vake always so uh uh on
on Wednesday when we did this town hall
the Tim cast team was like they come to
me and they go we asked everyone who's
coming to the show to write down a
question and then we're going to go
through them and figure out which ones
are good I'm like no that sounds
terrible I was like we don't want to do
that like that's like cor corporate
garbage and they're like yeah but
someone's going to scream something
crazy and I'm like I'm pretty sure if a
will say no he will not accept that and
I was like I don't think we do that I
think it's good they prepared questions
but we're going to call him it random
and so I told V hey my team I don't know
what you what your policy is but my team
had everybody draft questions it goes we
I never it's my policy to take no
screened questions let them ask whatever
they want there's viral video of Ronda
santis throwing people out of his events
who said nothing right just cuz he's
scared of of who they may be associated
with right yeah yeah there was a guy the
other day in a wheelchair in yeah in a
wheelchair and so you had you had VI
gets this Heckler the woman starts
screaming something about climate change
and he's like how about this I'll make
you a deal I'll hand you the microphone
for 60 seconds you make your case and
then I'll talk you know then I'll talk
about it as well yeah I'll tell you why
you're wrong and it was it was a great
moment she was confused she made a
terrible case he was able to trounce it
in a second and then there was a clip of
danta dealing with a Heckler being like
no I'm doing this I'm doing this you
know no no respect no consideration at
all just sort of you know like musling
his way past the guy it was it was
really distasteful I want to go back to
March of 2020 when I think I went to the
last fundraise that Trump hosted for dis
santis it was at maral Lago somebody got
Co one of the chefs so they they still
went ahead with the fundraise but it was
closed about 80 people these F these
colleagues old colleagues and friends I
had from Long Island they hosted it for
the santis March of 20 21 so he's he was
just it was still a year to go running
for a second term I go in there I'm with
my Dad I'm with other friends i i r up
to very close to the Govern I'm trying
to talk to them I'm getting nothing out
of him I'm doing my best I just moved
here from New York it's terrible the
policies I couldn't get anything out of
them that I remember if you meet the
sitting governor who's doing a great job
I'm trying to get a conversation and
nothing's coming out of him no
personality which you can remember what
do we have memories in life I can't
remember talking to the governor cuz
nothing came out of him Trump is there
he sees my dad at Clear distance is that
your dad he says get him over here I
want to take some photos and talk to him
that sums up the difference in that
little in that little you know moment in
time and that Trump held those last
fundraiser for Des santis that that
sticks out that kind of sums up the
personalities I'll tell you uh the first
story I've ever heard of Donald Trump
outside of like the media I was in
Chicago and I met this guy who was a
music producer young guy like you know
collegee music producer and he said that
he would was uh I think he was doing
some kind of delivery when he's going to
Trump Tower to drop off some a package
or something Donald Trump is coming up
behind him as he's walking in and he
holds the door open for Trump and his
team as he walking in and then he walks
in behind him Trump stops and goes hey
kid thanks and he throws him an iPod
this is back in the day when iPods were
like several hundred dollar and it meant
something but the kid caught it and he
was like whoa like I held the door over
this guy me you hear I hear stories like
that all the time where Trump stops to
make sure leaves you with a positive
impact when I went to Trump Tower during
his campaign cycle in
2015 I was with uh uh some colleagues
and I was like Hey we're you know we're
covering Trump's rallies we're covering
Trump let's go see what his employees
have to say about him so we decided to
get food at the uh Trump Steak House
asked everybody what they thought of
trump they love the guy they love him I
went to he has an ice cream shop
downstairs and I asked him and the
people working there said Trump will
show up randomly and walk call call all
the staff out and just hand everyone
$100 bills and everyone is like we're so
excited when Trump comes he's such a
nice guy shakes everybody's hands thanks
them for their work and then gives them
$100 cash to be fair Tim does this too
we'll just gather around staff meeting
hands meeting here's money no I'm just
kidding Tim doesn't do that no we play
poker I take the money from you and Tim
just like s and stuff it's fine no but I
I think that's true Trump had that
personality and it stayed true when he
was president I mean the presidency I
could see potentially you dial it back a
little bit you have to whatever my one
of my favorite clips of trump ever is
when he and Melania my favorite first
lady were handing out um Halloween candy
and someone comes up in like a Minion's
costume he like puts this full-sized
chocar in this kid's head and he's
obviously laughing like there was
something pull that up please do it's my
f one of my favorite Trump clips of all
times there is something you know he's
Brash there are times you don't like him
whatever there is such a personality
that is true and authentic there that
you you kind of laugh along with him
last night here we go can we just can we
just play this real quick cuz it's like
it's the best one of the best clips of
trump ever there little spider two two
Spider-Mans
and a unicorn princess M like here the
look look at this the kids hands he
can't reach his
head they both put candy bars on and
then they that's amazing they slide off
and fall in a little girl's back and and
it's Melania who's like well I'll give
you another one like hold on don't leave
yo that is one of the best moments ever
funny look at him he like test it out
make sure it doesn't hurt him and then
look it slides off the head and lands
right in the girl's bag oh no they found
the floor fell on the floor that's why
she gives her another one then someone
comes and picks him up oh my God the kid
in the minion's costume his arms can't
reach above his head it's it's just
these small things or there's another
one where he's on the phone we don't
have to play this CP but they're taking
calls from kids around Christmas and
there's one where he's like uh you know
wishing it he's like how old are you
seven Merry Christmas so do you believe
on Santa that's right on the edge like
where are we like he just has the
personality that shines through and I
think so many Americans like that
because it's not stiff and formal I
worry I think you know I think Ronda
Sanz could have a political future I'm
not one to speculate what it could be
but you know it it sort of embracing
that personal connection that people are
really craving in this day and age and
it has so much to do with our our
personal interactions with our neighbors
falling apart to see a president that
you can all kind of share these memories
with and laugh like that's something
people desperately want and the
politicians that can do that like Trump
like vake Thrive I made it the Heartland
proved last night they love a funny
Brash fighter New Yorker right and
that's we proved it again last night and
the culture Hollywood the media used to
love Trump until until three four nine
years ago until he decided to say I'm a
republican I'm running for office all of
a sudden he wasn't there well he was
great for headlines right he's still
great for headlines still great for
headlines but it's negative headlines it
used to be all positive Trump was a you
know an icon in New York he did so many
wonderful things building this skat and
rink he paid for Jesse Jackson's office
for the Rainbow Coalition oh really yeah
back in the day inter I didn't know that
let's jump to this story we have this
tweet from Team Trump flashback Trump
said you know I just found out that
Democrats are funding Nikki Haley's
campaign I hear that Democrats are
contributing to Ron DeSantis let me uh
play the clip for you guys I just found
out that Democrats are funding Nikki
Haley's campaign I hear that Democrats
are contributing to Ronda santis or
Ronda San demonius to Ronda San's
campaign I I got to stop you there Trump
it's it's dampas okay dampas was always
the best name but he went with the
Sanctus whatever but the conspiracy
theory now I suppose I don't think it's
actually a conspiracy theory I think
it's a fact we know for a fact that
Nikki Haley is getting support from
Democrats many of the voters that are
coming out and voting for her in Iowa
that voted for her in Iowa are liberal
individuals and we have the proof it's
in the pudding the Iowa caucus results
Trump lost only one Precinct and it was
by one vote actually it looks like he
may have reclaimed it so this was uh
where do we have Johnson County oh okay
no no Johnson County look at this
they're not even showing it anymore uh
Johnson County is the only County that
went for Nikki Haley by one vote and as
it's pointed out to us this is the urban
liberal college area so it's not
surprising that's what's happening but
that would mean that many of people are
coming out for Nikki Haley they're in
Liberal areas they are liberal Democrat
voters and then we have this from The
New York Times in Iowa Nikki Haley has
the attention of Democrats and
Independence is attracted the interest
of non- Republicans who say they'll
caucus for her as Rivals attack her for
an insufficiently conservative message
this is the play ladies and gentlemen we
were
speculating how are they going to get
Joe Biden out of the race Joe Biden
would have to suffer some injury get
sick but then it he's passed the point
at which the Democrats can have a
primary so then people said it won't
happen a strategist for JP Morgan said
no he'll he will drop out uh due to a
medical issue and my response was it
make that's actually smart it allows
them to Appo point an nominee bypassing
a primary preventing a Bernie Sanders
situation V is smarter he act he pointed
out and I believe he's correct he said
no The Establishment play is the primary
it's Nikki Haley the Deep state will
stop at nothing to remove Donald Trump
and when they do it's going to be Nikki
Haley versus Rona santis and Nikki will
win and that's how they're going to take
back the system and we get more Wars we
get World War III I think that's
actually what's happening right now when
you look at the Democrats voting for
Haley the New York Times is saying it
outright donated Nikki Haley they
realized we cannot win a general
election against Donald Trump however
Donald Trump will struggle to win Blue
State primaries if they if Democrats
come out and vote for Nikki Haley so
this she's Hillary you of course you can
no you can't you can't do that in every
primary yes you can well you'd have to
change your some of them you have to
change your voter registrations that far
in advance yep and so these people have
been planning this for look look the
said they'll stop at nothing and we
can't look back on this in 2025 and say
how did we not see this coming he's
correct so how many votes do they need
to beat Donald Trump Nikki Haley got
what nine delegates let me let me what
is it she got uh eight delegates eight
she got eight delegates in Iowa she's
behind Ronda Sanz but she is polling in
uh in the high double digit or I should
say uh uh near as high as Trump in New
Hampshire and it is speculated these are
Democrat voters that have switched their
parties this is this is it I mean in New
Hampshire you don't have to be switch a
party you can be an independent Democrat
vote in the prime right and so for for
places where you need to be a registered
party member like in a caucus you just
do it in advance super easy and then
there states with open primaries what I
think we're seeing are actually rather
fascinating is the end of the democratic
party when when they realize you can't
beat Donald Trump in a general election
their only plan their only path is to
beat him in a primary it's actually kind
of scary if you think about what comes
after this if there if the general
election doesn't matter CU it's Joe
Biden with no support the Republican
Party becomes the single party rule in
this country and while many people may
may say oh but that's great we like
Republicans we'd rather they win than
Democrats no but you don't understand
it's Democrats weaseling their way into
the Republican party as their only means
of stealing power and then instead of
having general elections we have whoever
our president going to be is going to be
solely based on who wins the Republican
primary yeah I mean I think it's getting
pretty desperate uh on I honestly on
both sides of the aisle right there are
a ton of people who do not want Trump to
be the nominee they don't outnumber the
people who want him to be the nominee
but the tactics are there when ASA
Hutchins dropped out one of the the
pieces that I read when I was
researching for my article was uh the
recommendation from a Republican
strategist that he endorsed Nikki Haley
who he shares more votes with you know
he's this long-term governor from
Arkansas uh I think there are going to
be sort of moments until the end until
her campaign is over where people are
trying to say well if just the right
people and she got some states we can
still make this happen they're still
away to deny Trump and I think that's
ultimately uh denying reality at this
point yeah I think you have something
interesting Tim because I saw a
colleague a friend from The Hamptons an
older gentleman AE Sab and he was on
Neil Cavuto last week I was just
thinking about that and he said the
interesting thing we're doing a
fundraise of finiki at the end of a
month and a lot of Democrats are coming
yeah he said believe it or not a number
of it is coming from Democrats
Democratic fundraises are coming and
they're doing a big fundraiser in New
York for Nikki haly why would they why
would they join Nikki Hy Democrats and
what's what are Nikki H's
positions proar proar don't call illegal
immigrants criminals right register with
the government before you comment
anything online social media y she yeah
she's uh she's definitely sort of the
the Hillary Clinton of this campaign
she's even running on you know I'm a
woman elect me that that's a
qualification somehow and she likes to
talk about her high heeled shoes none of
sad I think if you were really a
candidate you wouldn't have to like you
being one would be like a fun benefit
right but it wouldn't be the ma major
tenant of your campaign this uh ad
impacted the study and they were talking
about uh the top themes that each of the
candidates during their ad spend have
because Republicans have spent like $230
million so far and Trump is talking
about illegal drug trafficking he's
talking about the Border he's talking
about policy he's talking about trade
and both DeSantis and U Nikki Haley are
talking about China which you know fair
and they're talking about character
which is just code for they're trying to
say we're better than Trump and I can't
even remember the last thing they talked
about because it's just so irrelevant
they are trying to separate themselves
from Trump and Trump is the one setting
the pace for polic the thing is Trump is
able to run on a lot of the same
policies and ideas that he did in 2016
because he had four years he did a lot
of really good things Biden took over
literally reversed everything on purpose
and now it's like oh we're still we're
back here now we have to redo it even
look at the situation with the uh the
hooes in Yemen right you had um you had
Trump when he was leaving office
classified the houis as terrorists at
the day he came into office Biden
reversed that and he said no they're not
a they're not terrorists and the reason
that he firsted it was for apparently
humanitarian reasons which is the same
reason we're throwing money at Gaza
right so that Hamas can masser people
again um but now he's talking now
Biden's talking about oh I better make
the houthis classify them as terrorists
and it's like they've been terrorists
this whole time you know so he literally
came into office reversed all the good
things Trump did made a whole bunch out
of spite out of spite that was whole
bunch of really bad things and in terms
of the border wall reversed the concept
of the border wall and then left all the
equipment and supplies just sitting
there rotting waiting for nothing you
know with people climbing over it and
then had to like re restart up the
border wall anyway even though now
that's you know irrel well now because
it's humanitarian it's just too late
they're going to try and spin it so that
like whatever they did was the correct
thing to do but so Trump is able to run
on the same stuff that brought him into
office in the first place the same
reason now on to the good things Joe
Biden has
done oh it's very quiet now he's got a
33% approval rating it's rough can we
can we think of any let's be as nice as
we can um nothing can't he's been Pro um
pardoning people for some drug drug
offenses which like depending on your
stance on that that could be perceived
as a good thing um he's given up some of
the best memes of the the marijuana
pardoning thing was done because there's
nobody in prison at the federal level
Federal exactly for possession when all
the ramous left uh progresses with
anti-israel he stood up a little bit but
I just read recently he hasn't talked to
Biby uh the prime minister in like 3 or
four weeks right incredible being being
wishy-washy is like what's a good thing
he's done being like halfway there is
not a good thing it's like well he was
like T it here no no no what was he good
on I'm gen I'm trying to be honest like
can we I want to think of something I
feel like if you it's too easy be like
everything he did is awful and he's
terrible like I want to be you know you
know analytical and say like well maybe
this was good but it's very hard well I
I I remember during Trump's presidency
so when he won in you know when he won
in 2016 I remember thinking okay like I
didn't vote for Trump in 2016 but he's
the president I'm going to support the
president and I'm going to watch what he
does and see you know see what his
policies are and go from there and then
every like he kept coming out with
policies I was like that's good well
that's good that's good and with Biden I
did the same thing I was like I didn't
vote for Biden you know I wisened up I
voted for Trump I didn't vote for Biden
and I I thought okay well I'll you know
I'll watch I'll see what he does and
everything that he did every EX
executive order I kept reading the
executive orders this is terrible idea
this is this is destructive this is
destroying everything um I can't think
I've been tracking his his time in
office since he took over and I can't
think of a single good thing that I that
he did where I was like oh that's good
I'm glad he did that I can't think of
anything at all yeah I mean even with
Obama I remember you know he made some
efforts to uh encourage private
investment investment in space travel
and I was like that's Hunter Biden on
the board of the space travel company
it's always the question I mean it's
it's it's to me not a good sign that
there is a president that we can't off
the bat be like this one seems okay well
look at what he did on his first day in
office right he pushed Equity he pushed
weird gender stuff he reversed the
border wall he Declassified the houthis
as terrorists he did so many terrible
things and he said during his first
campaign speech a couple weeks ago you
know the the Republicans are all focused
on the past and then all he did was talk
about January 6 but that's actually been
the theme of his administration the
whole time I mean he has everyone is
saying well Trump is saying revenge and
he's going to do whatever but actually
it's Democrats who have been acting out
of spite right the fact that he reversed
his first day in office reversed a ton
of trump policies just because Trump did
them to prove to his base that Trump is
bad and then let us all suffer the
consequences of his you know spite is
not good what what out of the two of
them who talks more about the future and
who harps on the past non-stop the
Democrats harp on the past let's jump to
the story from the Independent to santis
Fury after Trump has projected Iowa
caucus winner before some even started
voting language from the desis campaign
Echoes Trump's own election denialism
it's kind of sad because desas had said
previously that if Donald Trump loses in
Iowa he will claim it was fraudulent or
it was uh untour or something like that
and now that Donald Trump has won it is
actually the s's campaign saying that
something was a ow here but here's the
real conspiracy my friends as many of
you may know if you were watching the
Iowa caucuses last night within about a
half an hour of the caucus beginning
they called the race for Donald Trump
the Associated Press said we have seen
enough Trump is the winner now of course
The Descendant campaign is saying that's
not fair people haven't voted yet this
is a trick to help Donald Trump Des
Sis's campaign staff even said that the
media's pro Biden they want Trump to be
the nominee because they want Trump to
run against Biden so Biden can beat him
these people are as dumb as a box of
rocks I'm sorry that's offensive to
rocks the reality is this was a play
against Donald Trump and I'll break it
down for you and I am right okay maybe
I'm wrong but okay but hear me out think
about this who is who whose election is
it to lose Donald Trump if you are a
disantis supporter you know entering
this race you are facing an uphill
battle you know that that if you want
Ron to win you must fight tooth and nail
and so you're sitting there ready to
caucus and you get a push notification
that says Trump is the winner you knew
you knew Trump was the favorite here you
know that to win you must do your duty
why would you leave now hold on you're a
trump supporter you know Trump is going
to win everyone is telling you the race
is pointless why are we even having a
primary Trump is up 30 40 points you're
sitting there in
minus5° in your caucus location and your
phone bur and you look down it says
Trump is the projected winner already
and you go okay I knew we won I don't
need to be here everybody knew Trump won
I'm going home the reality is it was
Trump's to lose and the only people who
I would say Trump supporters are more
likely to leave having already believed
they were going to win in the first
place th and and this is brought up by
Trump and many Republicans that because
the polling favors Trump so much Trump
supporters are more likely to be like
well I guess Trump already won why do I
need to show up this is what they warn
about some people say this is what cost
Hillary Clinton 2016 they were so
confident Hillary would win that many
Democrats were like why even bother
showing up so this is not a play against
as santis it is not media bias for trump
it is media bias against Trump to trick
Trump supporters and it didn't work or
if it did it wasn't enough and you got a
great point then because right before we
went on air I read an article political
on their newslet it says Trump won but
only 7% of the Republicans came out so
that's their story line right lowest
turnout in in in a decade so if you're
standing online or waiting to vote and I
it wasn't there you were how cold is it
you're like oh Trump want let me go home
you're not going to wait anymore ex but
if you're a disantis Haley or if you're
an opposition voter you're going to be
like we all knew they were going to call
it for Trump we have to stay here and
try and get our candidate to win if if
you know come
2024 we I mean the election in November
Trump supporters are not going to back
down because they know you need a
tsunami of votes to win this is why I
think the play is to get this is why I
think the primary is the general Nikki
Haley is the Democrat she's running in
the primary to beat Trump and she's
going to try and beat him in in major
Urban uh uh
strongholds the play here is well it's
basically that they are going to try to
convince Trump supporters that the GOP
Primary it's done deal done deal Trump
can't lose don't even bother coming out
and that might work see cuz everybody's
saying come November everyone must vote
bring your F friends don't assume Trump
will win because that's how they trick
you but in the primary everyone's I got
Trump won already and RF RFK gave up on
the primary right he said this is you
know r r but at first he was a Democrat
he said this is to rig I can't run in
there there's another congressman who
believe his name is Dean Phillips ran
he's getting no attention so Phillips is
doing I think he's doing okay in New
Hampshire right now so the play is
probably let's get as many Democrats as
we can in New Hampshire and vote for
Nikki heli and this way we can somehow
stop Trump if we can if she can win New
Hampshire then it's you know Nikki ahead
this is what and the media and people
are missing out that there's going to be
Republican primaries in blue States
Nikki Haley could win those so how many
ways are they trying to stop Trump right
now they're trying to pull him off the
ballot right they're trying to send him
to prison in New York Georgia and at the
federal level uh they're they're driving
crazy with civil suits they're driving
een Carol and the stupid Laticia James
one you know you took out loans and paid
them back that's a criminal offense
right so you crazy crazy man crazy how
dare you wait he he won the Primary last
night he flew to New York and sat in
this Civil Trial that's
aarug and then he just flew back to New
Hampshire and did it the the energy this
man is amazing I know at his age it's
incredible yeah people people will will
tell me I work a lot right cuz I'm
barely functioning off any sleep right
now and I'm like don't look at me look
at Trump no no question I mean he's
flying nonstop I I don't even know how
he does it I don't know how you do it
and I don't know how Trump does it man
it's hard interesting everywhere up the
level cuz you all work really hard I
mean like both of you exem long days but
like I'm not flying back from Iowa at
3:00 morning I got to start eating more
McDonald's Trump eats McDonald's must be
like a diet C the golfing you got to
start
golfing does not want to stop start I'm
not going to eat McDonald's it was the
Sunday before 2020 right before the
election and it was I was at a private
Aviation airport it was his fourth rally
of the day fourth it was 12:30 at night
he started the rally I turned around I
saw New Yorkers I knew and Floridians
everywhere it was think 5,000 people I
said there's no way he's going to lose
his election it's 12:30 at night there's
5,000 people in say fourth stop and he
spoke for an hour and 15 minutes to 2
a.m. yeah I said how does he humanly do
this if you told most humans you got to
do two stops today and do two speech
that's I don't know if I can do that but
he's also so personable I mean like last
night at his victory speech he brought
brick suit up on stage you know that was
that was so cool and I like brick suit I
think he's a really swell guy and I
thought that was great like he he
notices his supporters he calls them out
you know and he's just like so present
in the room with people I've seen him
speak a couple of times and usually it's
at these like giant you know giant
things um and it's always personable
yeah he has and he can feel I mean we
might just credit him with being an
extrovert here he really does feed off
the energy of people and being around
people an introverted person would be
like this is too much I must leave
immediately um but I think Trump's
energy also underscores how tired
Biden's campaign already is right they
should just go back to that basic put on
The Masks right Trump is younger than
Biden by what two three years but Biden
seems exhausted and he is in the white
house with every around man he has the
old man walks he has a slur he has like
his voice has audibly changed and it's
just rough you you can't make weekend up
Bernie's jokes about Trump you know what
I was thinking just like totally for no
reason it's nonsensical but all the
things like there's a lot of things we
don't like about Joe Biden that are
perfectly acceptable if he was a golden
retriever like first the obvious to
sniffing kids the dog runs up to the
kids sniffing nobody cares it's funny uh
uh fumbling around and falling down and
rolling on the ground we laugh oh puppy
fell down and then the muttering
incoherent nonsense when the dog walks
them goes we're laughing we're like I
wonder what but when Joe Biden does it
you're like this guy's got the nuclear
codes at least the dog always knows
where the stairs are right B never does
who would be a better president right
now a golden retriever or Biden rough no
no for real because paralysis is better
than whatever it is Biden is doing I
mean a Golden Retriever as president
CBP is going to come and be like sir
what should we do with the border and
it's going to go and they're be like we
have no we have no idea Joe Biden's like
facilitate human smuggling and then they
do yeah so at least the golden retriever
can't give orders that's true but he can
get belly rubs and he would just look
great make us all feel wonderful Joe
Biden were just like nervous about all
time Joe Biden getting belly rubs would
be alarming for the country no I don't
want to that would be really weird
wouldn't it and you notice how every
time he goes out there and gives a
speech what he really says is Trump
voters suck you notice how he
and it's like how would any of us ever
come vote for you all you do is tell us
that we're extremists that our religion
is bad even though you know we're
basically just Christian also
inconvenient you claim to be Catholic
right that's what I'm saying it's like
you know the FBI targets Catholics the
FBI targets parents who speak up at
Schoolboard meetings Joe Biden calls us
all extremists and we're supposed to
like come around and be like no it's
okay that you're you know destroying the
country and you hate us we're going to
vote for you anyway like why would you
vote for someone who just keeps telling
you that they hate you Adrianne Curry in
the chat says golden would have great
polling numbers no matter what it did
and that that gives me an idea like I'm
going to take a picture of a golden
retriever and just post it on X with a
poll like favorability rating favorable
unfavorable and I bet it's going to be
like 95% favorability dog people are
going to go berserk in your chat I feel
like they're G they're goingon to have
all kinds of comments about it people
feel really strongly about what's your
favorability of random dog I found on
internet yes you know I mean I would
think a border collie would be better
call for president it's smarter than a
golden retriever but a golden retriever
do less harm than Joe Biden I like a
yeah I like a corgi but that's the
British monarchy's dog they round people
we field occupied it'd be like a whole
thing I used to hang out with my friend
uh in Connecticut at his family's lake
house and we'd all go hang out but he
had this Corgi and all of us you know
goofy kids would be hanging out in the
in the yard and the Corgi would notice
that we weren't all in the same place
and would just start rounding us all up
and we be like oh my goodness Ginger
just rounded us all up my cousin had a
um an Australian Cattle dog that they
were like oh we'll rescue it but it was
from like a working dog line and you
know there were a lot of us growing up
and they would hurt us onto couches
would my little guy make great president
or what Sammy Sammy so cute cute tiny I
don't know if the cameras can see it but
it's a tiny tiny Chihuahua who's very
very very sweet Sammy um I mean what's
the stamina on this dog right like but
even last night uh Joe Biden's staffers
I guess tweeted out out at 11:30 p.m.
because of course Joe Biden was probably
asleep but tweeted out um uh looks like
Donald Donald Trump just on Iowa he's
the clear front runner on the other side
at this point here's the thing this
election was always going to be you and
me versus extreme Maga Republicans it
was true yesterday and it'll be true
tomorrow but they're the party of the
future but they're yeah they're the
uniting party they're the uniters and
you had Rachel mattow last night
bragging about how MSNBC was not going
going to show Trump's victory speech
because it's you know truth is really
important and then she starts talking
about Rising
authoritarianism and there she is
literally praising the network she works
for for censoring the guy who's giving a
speech thanking his opponents and
talking about
Unity that's crazy it's crazy even Obama
massed his even his terrible po but he
massed his speeches and positive you was
always looking up in how he won even
Clinton was and this guy is just
brutally negative half of the country
it's and fearmongering he wants the
people who do support him to be very
very scared of other people specifically
people who vote differently than them we
got a super chat from X10 man saying
he's going to uh go to the Democrat
ballot and WR in Haley WR in Trump yeah
that's better plan like what what if
every Republican in in in the Democrat
Prime well because they're not having
primaries I guess the Democrats are just
not doing it but what if every
Republican went to the Democrat primary
and Rod and Trump well that that's the
other thing is that the Democrats have
really snubbed New Hampshire this year
and and Iowa they they had they honored
Iowa but they're saying South Carolina
is the first primary caucus and that's
because Biden got wrecked in New
Hampshire last time and he won South
Carolina and so there they passed it off
as like well we need more diversity and
we need to be reflective of the voters
and so we're going to avoid New
Hampshire but they know probably if he
had to primary there I mean he's the
incumbent so it's it's a weird year but
he would not do well New Hampshire
doesn't like him let's jump to this
story we have a tweet from George I
don't know you George but uh you have
this tweet breaking Trump crowd chance V
PV PVP after V gets done speaking Trump
says he's going to be working with us
for a long time here's the video clip
let's play it for you right
[Applause]
now good to see you
guys thank you thank you wow that's how
was that pretty good right that was
pretty good and he's a fantastic guy and
he's really uh he's got something that's
very special because he started off with
the Zippo and he's got he ended up very
strong he did a great job I was actually
surprised when he called because he was
doing well and it's an honor to have his
endorsement he's going to be working
with us and he'll be working with us for
a long time he's going to be working
with us for a long time because uh we we
we were talking about this a little bit
before the show V needs to work in a
trump Administration if he's going to be
the next guy after Trump and I think he
can be he needs government experience
one of the one of the pitfalls one of
the reasons why V was not the guy this
time around Trump had that first term he
walked to the Minefield he hit some of
these mines he knows where some of them
are he can do a better job this time
around perfect no good yes VI good
speaker good ideas great ideas in fact
but he doesn't know where those
landmines land landmines are in the same
way Trump does so if aake gets a
position in the Trump Administration
ation then coming into 2027 he begins
campaigning he will have the experience
behind him and I got to tell you man
Trump is this unrefined ore and V is
refined when When Donald Trump explains
something it works for the average
person and he's he's this rash crash guy
who's going to say it like it is the
vake can lay it out analytically and
just he can sell it to you so I think
this team up I don't know to what extent
what do you guys think you think he's VP
I think that would be great what do you
think Adam I don't think he's VP he's
just too big of a personality I think
he's a cabinet secretary because cabinet
secretary your name will be constantly
in the news you can go on TV all the
time you can create policy you could you
could be a you know be ready prepared
for
2028 VP I think he needs someone like
Trump needs someone like a Tim Scott a
more calmer cars par Carson Tim Scott
just sorry keep going the alpha that
Trump is and I feel like Vivic is an
alpha but more refined like you said
would just be too much together it's
just you can't put two electric like
Outlets you can't put two positives
together would just spark too much right
you can't do that yeah Secretary of
State what do you think Secretary of
Energy Secretary of Commerce maybe Chief
maybe uh you know Chief of Staff but
personal might be too big for Chief of
Staff just he needs a front- facing
position because he's so good on camera
he's really Charming he can really
communicate a message think think about
him on TV every week Meet the Press or
you know National talking that Economic
Policy you run circles around these
people someone like a blank great yeah
you want him to be front facing for sure
um I you know I take him seriously when
he came on this show and said that he
didn't want to be VP and I think Tim's
right that having more experience in the
government would be good and in some
ways VPS aren't super known for what
they contribute to to uh an
Administration there's a rumor that
it'll be doug berham because based on
what Trump said last night bergham was
back was with him there he endorsed him
didn't he ended him and last night when
Trump was giving his remarks he said
something like oh he's going to he's
going to be around like he had this like
smirk and bur 2024 I don't know and no
one will see that coming I think that's
sort of I think he needs uh you know he
but he needs a personality that's
quieter than fakes and bergham is I
totally disagree he had Mr quiet
personality and stupid Pence and that
didn't work out I think he should go for
someone nice and big Tulsi gabard Tulsi
I like Tulsi I like Tucker I like
anybody who can go out there and rev up
a crowd almost as good as Trump does
because also he's going to need somebody
on the campaign Trail while he's being
dragged around by you know stupid
Merrick Garland and his minions yeah I
would love to see Trump just put a candy
bar on Merrick Garland's head so funny
again it was one of the best moments ter
I think that there are a lot of
potentially good picks I think Bergen
would be weird because North Dakota is
not you know necessarily a stronghold I
guess it's it's different um but the way
he was talking about him there is there
is a belief that bergham is involved
somehow so you could start piecing
together who his cabinet to be my
question with vake and you know it could
be great for him to gain experience on
the federal level and then potentially
run again in
2028 I wish that he would take some of
the really Innovative things that he
talked about like Civic engagement and
and different things during his campaign
and apply it on a small scale in in Ohio
it's just that the timing doesn't line
up where he could take a position in
Ohio and then run again in 2028 from
what from what I
know I don't know berham does not seem
like VP that that's that that you may as
well put just Trump blank yeah like I
don't I don't mean to be these cherry
picking like Democrats but I don't think
we need a white male from North Dakota
that help with the ticket that maybe I
like the old way where you just get the
second guy you know what I mean oh so
Biden no s Sant yeah but the old way was
whoever got second place in the general
would be the vice president yeah that's
how you Adams the the the argument there
was that the country would have
representation for those who lost the
election and it makes sense now it's not
so half the country feels
disenfranchised you know's very
articulate doing a great job out of New
York at leise the stonic the Congress
stonic has done a good job excellent
speaker she went to Harvard she's real
fighter I don't see VP there though to
toy gabber is a long shot but you kind
of make sense if people when people say
it you're like okay I can kind of
understand why she'd be VP um people
saying Christin n yeah she kind of feels
like VP and she's been a trump Ally for
a really long time with stepanic I
wouldn't want to lose her from Congress
I think she's doing really good things
and it's nice to see that representation
in New York I mean part of part of the
problem is that if you lift anyone out
of position they're currently in that
becomes a vacuum you don't know where
what's going to fill it I got it Trump
trump 2024 which one Baron Don yes
Junior Don Jun ER don junr don junr yeah
but then the Democrats would freak out
and be like he's just putting his own
kids in this is crazy he like George
Bush just like George and the Adams is
yeah it's Don junor is great uh but I
can understand why he's a family member
they wouldn't do it but I think Don junr
would be a great choice too do you think
he'd run for office on his own though I
mean would he run for state or you know
senate or something like that I don't
think I I don't know if Don Junior's
gonna go that
route I I don't know I don't see it I
think he could be a VP but I think the
play is to get someone outside of the
Trump space that's why Christy Nome
makes sense tulsy gabard could make
sense but it definitely seems like a
0.1% likelihood you know I like tulsy
gabard uh asvp because you know military
experience fairly moderate could attract
former Democrats and disaffected
liberals she would also do some work
right I mean KLA Harris doesn't do
anything at all telsey gabard would be
like I have a position I'm G to do some
stuff now KLA Harris entertains us every
day with her vep style speeches MH she's
unburdened by what might have been man
it is amazing when she says stuff like
the community is a good thing because
it's the community it's like and you're
like what what well and the Biden
Administration initially they had her
out there they moved her to the
background and now that we're getting
closer to 2024 they're kind of being
like it's the Biden Harris
Administration they really are trying to
sell that and it's for the middle two
years they were like stand in the back
and don't say anything because she was
just not good right well they were
trying to get her to do stuff and she
wouldn't do it remember the whole
borders are and then her office was like
no no she's not the borders are she's
working on the root causes of migration
in the northern triangle countries and
she's not even doing that and then she
was like actually it's
lgbtqia a plus violence that is the
problem so we need to prioritize them
for Asylum which then they had an EO
about that that's have have you guys
seen that Meme where it's a
lgbtq plus and it's let's get Biden to
quit plus Kamala
that very fny very funny people the
internet is undefeated I mean I wish we
could pick VP based on like what issue
they are going to rabidly Champion
during the administration because then I
would love to see you know a really
serious uh immigration restrictionist go
into office but I just don't think
that's going to happen so much of the VP
selection is saying who can we Court in
terms of um Electoral College votes and
where where's r k Jr is he still around
he was in North Carolina over the
weekend a lot was there covering him and
he has an V in West Virginia coming up I
I think he's doing pretty well for an
independent but you know he's not it's
sort of hard because he's not in the
news cycle because there's no primary
for the independent he's like either
just going to make it or not but he's
also I don't think he's taking the like
V went from zero was like in a year look
at this he went to to fourth place in
the primary he went to 8% in Iowa caucus
I mean this is amazing and he did it and
and it even you know got the Trump Camp
worried because he was getting so much
support but he went around the press
recuit he went to podcasters media
personalities and he and he made himself
available to them RFK is not doing that
so much he has an opportunity to get
attention he won't take it and that 8%
he took it took it right from Trump
those are all Trump voters well actually
technically yes or maybe he grew the pie
with young people he did that's what it
is uh so 30 so among firsttime voters V
was in first place and uh randis
actually according to one poll got more
gen Z than any other candidate but uh V
got a good amount of Trump supporters
but a lot of first-time voters so that's
I think that's the opportunity here for
Trump the targeting new voters brilliant
because now he goes to the Trump camp
and says I didn't think I was going to
be able to pull it off I didn't pull it
off you got my endorsement I can bring
in new voters for you and get those
numbers up I'm going to pull in voters
from areas you've never seen before yeah
that'd be cool and I think that's a good
sign for you know conservative values or
maybe libertarian values generally
because they were really drawn to to uh
RAM Swami's campaign and ultimately
that's the future right so it's easy to
focus on what happens this November but
what we want long term is for new voters
to be interested in voting for
candidates represent long-term
investment in a future that's going to
be steady and provide a prosperous life
for a lot of people well part of the
problem with that is that we have no
shared vision of either America's future
or of America's past yeah we have no
real social cohesion or vision for what
the American character is or
understanding of where we came from it's
just a
a constant fracturing but when do you
think the fracture started do you have a
an
estimate this is something that is you
know that has recently been coming up I
was actually talking to um inz stepman
today about it on her podcast high noon
uh something I've been talking to Jack
pic about he's been talking about
leftist revolutions and it was actually
really fascinating he had this series on
human events daily during the um period
between Christmas and New Year's and it
was like four I think it was four
episodes
about cultural revolutions or like
leftist revolutions and it was
uh I forget what they all were but there
were a bunch of them and they were
really fascinating but the one that I
found Most Fascinating was the one about
the 1960s in America the cultural
revolution in America which I had never
conceived of as a
revolution I'd never conceived of it as
a leftist revolution you know to a
certain extent I just thought of it as
you know my stupid parents were they're
not stupid I love you guys mom and dad
your silly parents my parents were sort
of part of the whole hippie thing they
were Boomers they came of age during
that period I thought you know it just
it seemed like a very cultural moment
and it was something where you know
fashion would take from it as I was
growing up it was always like now we're
in the 60s moment again now we're in it
again now we're it again um but I never
thought of it as a revolution and I've
been thinking about that uh a lot and
then you know the civil rights movement
and that whole era which I always had a
very I thought I had a very clear view
of it and I've been reconsidering it um
but I think that a lot of it started
then when you had this huge generation
of young people saying to their parents
everything you taught us was wrong
everything you thought about the country
is Wrong everything you think about us
and our future is wrong we're going to
destroy everything you built we're going
to dance around in that rubble and we're
going to build on top of rubble and I
think that's what happened so then when
you hit the '90s which in my view like I
was in my 20s I guess in the '90s
um you hit the 90s when you had a very
what what seemed to me a colorblind
Society you had a lot of great culture
um it was like you know I was hanging
out with a bunch of Art Kids downtown
New York City and there was just money
everywhere it's like you'd go out and
like somebody would pick up the tab
somebody would you know somebody would
fund the Giant art show there was money
left over who even knows who even knows
what was going on um but you know it
seemed like this Pinnacle of
civilization but it was really
apparently just built on top of rubble
you know the rubble of our
grandparents of our religion of our
culture of our shared past of our
appreciation for our history I grew up
at a small town on Long Island Port Jeff
Station and my neighbors were
African-American black but never had
discussions about race never had
discussions about any of this and we
were just my neighbor and we we liked
each other and got along well saying all
along my life had black friends never
thought of it I think somewhere along
the line when Obama got elected at the
very beginning of his term there was
this uh you know incident at Harvard
University with this black professor
right off the bat and the police called
because he was being obnoxious he was
screaming something about a beer right
off the bat the president of the United
States took the side of the obnoxious
professor that's right and went against
the white police officers and it became
a race issue M when it had nothing to do
with race and the media jumped on this
and said they need a lesson the police
need to go to you know sensitivity
training and I think somewhere that
incident I feel like stood out really in
this lesson where Obama wanted to turn
back the clock on race relations and I
feel like that's kind of like there was
the start of it he have had a beer
Summit for what because the guy was
being obnoxious and had to accuse the
white police officers I think Obama had
a negative impact on race relations but
uh all of this started with social media
the evidence is every single country
experienced the exact same thing at the
exact same time and the only uh uh
connected Factor would be the Advent of
social media emerging in all these
countries what happens is for Facebook
uh at the time and Twitter wasn't really
that prominent but you know Barack Obama
used Facebook to get elected it was it
helped him get out the youth vote what
happens is
as this the platform gets bigger they
need to find a way to keep people
interested in the platform when their
feed is SL was inundated with too much
content when these platforms first
started you'd see an update every few
seconds and you didn't care cell phones
come out now Facebook is ubiquitous
everyone's on Facebook 24/7 and you're
following more than 300 people your feed
becomes incomprehensible moves too quick
so they create the algorithmic feed what
only shows you some content some of the
time what happens the stuff that gets
the most clicks was related to to racism
it actually was related to a couple
other is a couple issues um white
nationalism uh not not entirely but uh
you know right strong nationalist
Christian and white nationalist uh
content was was prominent as well as
social justice content however these big
tech companies you know when you get
these Free Speech individuals in the
early days they call themselves like the
Free Speech we of the Free Speech party
on Twitter they they they look at it
very uh economically they said board
meeting and someone says okay A large
group of people are posting about white
nationalism and a large group of people
are posting about black
nationalism and they go okay well look
advertisers will not buy on your
platform if there's white nationalists
here ban them all advertisers don't care
about black nationalism it's fine what
ends up happening is people have an
option to click on the
most uh I guess bity rage bity content
they can and for these biased reasons
the algorithm algorithm will always
favor anger and Justice over every other
emotion and Justice can take the shape
of many things but when you combine it
you end up with police brutality like
things like you mentioned like this
professor but if the tech companies are
like if a white guy is murdered in the
streets and people start defending him
and saying you know white people under
attack oh we we got white supremacists
delete that stuff advertisers will flee
but if it's you know black people
Mexicans Asians or whatever that's
acceptable a bunch of companies started
mass-producing this social media company
started mass producing this and then we
see in every single country country a
massive spike in support for these these
issues when it started it was police
brutality which turned into feminist
issues intersectional feminist issues
and now we're into fullscale diversity
inclusivity Equity
Etc yeah it's interesting I mean I think
it's hard to say I think social media
was sort of the gasoline to a lot of
underlying cultural tensions that have
been building for a long time the
machine right and I think that's the the
hard thing dial the clock back on right
like you might be able to say to people
oh here's what happened during this
event with Obama and they might be able
to say oh okay but they won't forget the
fact that they felt this way for a long
time and they'll be constantly driven by
algorithms that want them to feel
divided because that ultimately sells
more than anything else I I think
because they probably figured that
happiness we can't keep people on the on
our platform too long if it's just happy
so let's constantly create conflict well
it's it's sort of it's It's they don't
think about that they think think about
what will get someone to spend more time
on the platform they need posts to look
at that they engage with what do they
engage with well on Facebook actually
the top engaged with uh kind of post is
I'm married and had kids so uh I don't
they may have fixed this but the meme
was if you ever had an important
announcement for your friends and it's
like you got a new job where you're
moving start the post off with I have
just gotten married and I'm having kids
okay now that I've said that none of
that's true I'm actually moving hope to
see you guys at the party this weekend
because it'll it'll put that at the top
of their feeds
but I don't think for a lot of these
people it was intentional I think as I
described it people like Jack dorsy he
basically built a big toilet for
everyone to sit on and then he hooked up
the pipes from that toilet into his own
mouth so they build this machine the
machine favors content that gets clicked
the most here's here's an example
YouTube wanted to uh compete with
Netflix YouTube used to get if if you
know uh we go back in the days of like
autotune the news shimo Yoho SFI they're
getting millions of hits per video all
of a sudden the views start dropping I
actually talked with Google about it and
they said Netflix is is our biggest
competitor and I said Netflix I was like
oh you're missing the big picture here
if you think it's Netflix their view was
what are people watching online it used
to be YouTube now it's Netflix Netflix
introduced streaming everybody signed up
they're getting premium content so
YouTube said we need to get our creators
to start making content that competes
with Game of Thrones so here's the idea
if your video long than 10
minutes and people watch it for a long
time that's what we want High retention
rates longer videos then people will
start producing shows like Game of
Thrones what did they get instead
timcast IRL how do you produce engaging
long form content video podcasts
vodcasts the problem with that is you
got a massive spattering of
argumentative and you know serious
political issues which generate a wave
of of nationalist white nationalist
racist all sorts of content and I'm not
saying only I'm saying it included
Everything YouTube then panics going oh
no that's not what we meant so these
companies don't actually care about what
the content is so long as it's making
money for them and if advertisers will
buy on the platform so they're not
thinking like I want people angry
they're saying tell the algorithm to
favor high high retention rates and long
videos what happens after this parents
would give iPads to their babies this
was part of the elsagate Scandal several
years ago it's like six seven years ago
now they would give an iPad to their
baby and leave the room they would press
play on finger family at the time it was
the most popular nursery rhyme have you
guys ever heard this one yeah yeah
finger family where are you whatever and
it goes index finger middle finger when
the song ends YouTube's autoplay feature
will load the next video automatically
so the parent puts the the iPad in front
of the baby the song ends another video
play play eventually it starts the
algorithm doesn't actually know what
finger family is there there were people
in India knowing this was the trend
started exploiting the algorithm by
producing extremely lowquality and
freaky videos like uh the example I have
give is the Incredible Hulk doing
taiichi with Adolf Hitler but goodness
but it's Hitler's head on an on a
woman's body with in a bikini and this
is not an
exaggeration what would happen is once
the audio once the parents would play
the video and the video would end it
would just autoplay the next video for
finger family and it just so happened to
be the Incredible Hulk and Adolf Hitler
but Hitler had boobs and it was weird
freaky stuff they didn't intentionally
make that happen it happened because all
they did was tell the algorithm to let
it go what what I've argued and I
believe this is the most likely scenario
as a baby you don't know what you're
watching so if you're watching finger
family and the next thing that pops up
is Hitler you're just a baby sing at
scen going but an adult can see that and
go whoa something is wrong here however
adults aren't immune to this either when
you're watching a video about a criminal
case involving a corrupt cop and you go
man the next video that plays is say
George Floyd or omed Arbury you go wow
you don't realize you're actually I'm
going to say this I will equate the omed
Arbury case to Adolf Hitler with a
woman's body doing taichi with the
Incredible Hulk as an adult it falls
into your preconceived notions and it
seems to make sense but the story is
totally fabricated and false everything
people know from the mainstream press
the Amed Arbury case what what who do we
have on the show recently they were like
oh that was the guy who was jogging
right and he wasn't jogging that was
never even a legal talking point the
courts they never argued that armed auy
was just jogging they actually conceded
he was a burglary suspect who had been
witnessed and was wanted by the police
for questioning but in the mainstream
media they were saying he was just
jogging that's these are people who live
in the world where they can't recognize
the algorithm is feeding them refu down
their throats and that's why I say the
people who running these companies
didn't one day decide let's produce a
bunch of rageful content to make them go
insane no Jack dorsy was like we're the
Free Speech we of the Free Speech party
then when the algor algorithms they
created were propping up the most
psychotic nonsensical garbage he took
that hose and shoved it straight down
his throat started absorbing it
believing it and sheded his own brain
the people then running these companies
adopted these views and integrated them
back into their systems exacerbating the
problem here we
are that's so true do you feel like this
is something that people who aren't
involved in alternative media aren't
aware of like if you were a longtime Fox
sort of corporate person would you be as
well versed in Elsa gate and all of this
stuff do you think you you have an
advantage because of the the medium
you're in you mean like the people who
are paying watching cable live in cable
TV world yeah I mean so this this is the
reality of 20 or 30 years ago if someone
went to CNN and said I have a huge story
and they were like we don't want to
cover that that's it never happens no
never hears about it and have a nice day
with the internet some random guy makes
a video and he's like I think ep's doing
something you end up with Alex Jones
massive personality generating Millions
outside of the controls of the deep
State I mean look we know about Mocking
Bird we know about how uh intelligence
agents would go to the press and say
Here's an article we wrote for you sign
your name on it not every journalist and
deep State narrative story is like that
most of them aren't we know they do that
the problem now is the only way to
control the narrative is through extreme
censorship and the problem there is a
decentralized press mechanism like what
we have now with shows like this can see
through it call it out causes problems
and they lose hence Donald Trump is the
front runner
do you think where we go I don't know
yeah that's the question I mean that's
my my big question for 2024 really has
been who is going to come come next
after this who's going to be sort of the
successor to the Trump movement because
he is such a personality that's the
that's the real shame with disantis it
should have been Dan santis no no I
think I think we're lucky with disantis
you think that we that we lucked out oh
we got so lucky in that he failed yeah
absolutely I mean this guy could have
been the a parent though no he couldn't
have and he and this is this is the
point it's a good thing he ran so that
we all got to see just how impotent he
was politically I mean the dude can't
run a campaign can't control the staff
he lacks can't hire he can't hire he
can't sell he can't he can't even pitch
and so if this guy did not run and
everyone kept praising him I like this
guy's so great and then 20128 comes
around and he goes well I'm here to take
over for Donald Trump uh here are my
high heels and here are the crackpots
that I've hired we'd be like oh crap but
he might have learned in the intervening
years he might have got better you no
look look there was can improve you
don't think people can improve not
Rhonda no stop we we were at um the
office building that we were in for the
Iowa cus was the same building as V's
campaign office for uh de Mo his
headquarters was at a different location
um at four that four caucus night I
think the office we were in was his
principal office we were not in his
office there's a distinction but we were
in the same building and we had to
negotiate with the building's owner so
it's not like you know V got us anything
but we were in the same space with him
he did help us find it that's no no
doubt but in one of the rooms they have
on this white board things successful
people do and I just laughed when I saw
it it's like they ask for help you know
they're Mission driven and I'm like
these are things you can't give people
okay I've been in so many corporate
meetings so many Corporate Offices where
it's like here's how to be successful
and they try to teach someone who
doesn't have The X Factor how to have
the X Factor and they don't so when I
used to do fundraising for nonprofits
what they decided was just give everyone
the lowest common denominator training
as to how you pitch someone to donate to
your cause and so they tell everybody
keep your feet spread open with your
with each foot lining up with your
shoulders keep your arms open never
cover your chest never hold a binder
over your chest those are all
off-putting bounce on the balls of your
feet and rock back and forth this is
what they tell everyone to do and here's
what you have to say and how you have to
say it and I'm
like if someone doesn't have the ability
to sell this will not help them right
and if someone does this will hurt them
so I look at Ronda santis totally
useless in other words totally totally
useless what you'd find is they would
tell you probably for legal reasons you
have to say this verbatim yeah right
everybody who went out to fund raise for
every nonprofit I ever worked with would
say whatever they felt like saying and
they would always sign people up and the
people who would always tried to do the
pitch would get super angry and be like
why can't I do this I I I've seen people
like Ronda sandz before okay I me and my
buddy got hired uh so I'll try to
simplify the story me and my buddy
worked for nonprofit they hired a woman
we were both managers she ends up
working underneath me she's brilliant as
soon as she gets trained by me one of
the top fundraisers in the nation she
she goes to another company and says I
want to be a director a position above
me I was trained by one of the nation's
best from this company and they were
like wow job's yours impressive resum
resume speaks multiple language has
training from one of the top fundraisers
in the country and then she immediately
hits me up and says you want to work for
me and I was like wow I am impressed and
so me and my buddy end up saying okay
fine screw it we'll go work for your
work for your office one of her friends
me it's it's it's three of us me my
friend and this guy this guy that she
hires is a friend of hers he doesn't
have it he is the Ronda STIs of
fundraising we are both Trump and V
gramas Swami of fundraising and so me
and him are standing there on the street
down in Chicago both of us are sitting
there with like glazed over looks on our
faces half paying attention expending no
energy this guy is doing everything he's
told standing upright balls of his feet
waving to people asking them asking them
asking them he's getting burned out me
and the other guy are sitting there and
then we see the person we that guy right
there you come over here sell him
instantly this guy freaks out gets
really angry and he was like I don't
understand I'm doing everything I'm told
to do and no one will talk talk to me
and then I'm watching these guys do
nothing and then just snap their fingers
and someone comes and signs up and I was
like what we have is the ability to
recognize someone who's interested open
willing to talk you're going about it
through the motions that's how I see
Rhonda santz he does not have the
abilities you can beg him to please
understand what he's doing wrong and we
tried and all that happens is he doubles
down with a CRA yeah absolutely he a
crackpot campaign staff what did they
say the media calling it for Trump was
actually Pro Biden and pro Trump and and
and the media's biased for Trump and
it's like you you've lost your minds
we've been warning the whole time since
since desus announced that his campaign
is garbage he has no Charisma he's a
he's failing and when it first starts
and we're polite about it like guys what
did we say first here on the show I was
like you got to get him speech training
and Charisma training and they said how
dare you and they started attacking all
of us insulting all of us and
Nows to attack everybody you have a you
have a good gift naturally a Salesman
but I tell people if like if you're
selling something let's say you're
selling real estate you walk in a room
you don't want someone just to bombard
you with your card just because you
don't want someone who was a needy and
pushy do the opposite get someone to
like you first be warm and Ron was never
been able to do the opposite he was just
a stiff he came across that way and I
would have told him Ron you got to be if
you can't if you don't have it just do
the opposite try to be warm but you know
you are correct but I don't think that's
the principal issue I think the
principal issue is that he's a loser and
I know that he he he won his
Congressional races we like the policies
he's got he won in Florida massively I
don't give him credit for all of it I
give him credit for some of it but the
re what I what I mean by loser
is when you're selling something it
doesn't matter if you know what it is it
matters that you sound like you do cuz I
don't know okay if I call a plumber and
I'm like guy my toilet's busted and he
goes well I mean I could probably fix it
I'd have to look at it I'm not you know
I think I could do it I'll be like okay
well you know let me give you a call
back then I call Trump plumbing and he
goes listen we're the best plumbers
we're going to come in fix it five
minutes easy cheap no one's better than
us everyone agrees well I'm going to be
like I want that guy get in here he cuz
he's he's at least just sound confident
and I think you might show up you know
and you know Gary Johnson exemplifies
this when he said and what is Aleppo
everyone knows the Aleppo moment that is
loser talk and I'm trying I'm kind of
trying to be in a dick but not really
I've I've often said if Donald Trump was
confronted with a with a with a subject
matter he didn't know about you so
imagine Trump's being interviewed and
someone says yes but as president how
will you H how will you handle Luc
andando Trump would go look you know
people have been talking about Luc
andando but the econ be is what matters
to the American people so we're going to
do that it's it's a gibber where I made
up but Trump would deflect by saying I'm
not going to sit here and talk about an
issue like that when the American people
are concerned about their jobs he Gary
Johnson goes what's that and everyone's
like he doesn't know what Aleppo is I
mean people are dying here this country
is being blown to smithin and so when
you look at Ronda
santz
listen if I'm gonna sell you
anything Who you gonna buy from the guy
who says
well I'm here to offer you a drink of
this uh delicious spin drift lemon drink
you'd be like okay or the guy walks in
and says this is the most delicious
drink I've ever had but I'll tell you
what I give you a little bit you got to
pay you're like oh what's this all about
confidence Charisma Ron does not have it
you can't give him it we tried all he
did was get a bunch like you know what
you know what I feel like with the
sandis people I feel like it's High
School really like High School Donald
Trump is like he's not necessarily a
football player he's he's like kind of
the bigger guy who hangs out with a
bunch of he's tall he's he's he's junky
but he's he's he's the jokester he's
funny people kind of like him and he's
the guy that everybody likes kind of
there's guy the guy in the middle who
got along with the Rockers and the
sports people yeah everybody liked him
and right and and and he's kind of a
dick sometimes but he always he'll rib
on you and say I'm just kidding and
they'll give you a shove and Ronda
santis is the nerdy kid in the glasses
with his dorky friends is being like you
know why don't people listen to us we're
smarter than they are people are so
stupid I bet if we tell them they're
stupid they'll listen to us yeah good
luck with that to santis congratulations
I feel like VI is the guy who was just
like what no I'm not paying any
attention to any of these people g go do
my own thing that's what he seems like
to me V is
like hang he's hanging out with the cool
kids and he's the shorter fast talking
guy you know so when I used to do
nonprofit fundraising two there are two
kinds of guys that made a bunch of money
tall guys and smooth talking guys
Trump's tall guy V's smooth talking guy
that's what it is Ron is the nerdy guy
who got fired in three days that that's
just the reality of it you know welcome
to politics I feel like V is fun because
then who's the Nikki who is Nikki Nikki
is like that girl student council it's
really annoying and she's always talking
about something that no one wants to do
and she's always trying to she's always
trying to drop bombs on foreign
countries and like teachers really like
her but it's hard to explain to them
that like no one else does and they're
like but why don't you just listen to
Nikki and you're like because Nikki has
trying to get everyone to blow up the
balloons for prom yeah but also like
it's a prom that she organized where no
one wants a date that's con inconvenient
for everyone else like she's ultimately
self-centered but she's passing it off
as like but I'm doing it for you guys
that's Nikki Haley to me that's
interesting yeah let's talk about on her
unprofessionally so we're just getting
off the holidays we have this story from
Seattle Times passengers Sue Alaska
Airlines Boeing after 737 max9 fuselage
blowout wow well that's the big news I
guess because it really does uh uh
matter to you if your plane is going to
you know have a blowout one of our
guests who was supposed to fly here on
United had their flight canceled because
they uh we got an email saying your trip
has been canceled because the Boeing 737
Max 9 has to be they're all being
inspected so this plane's no longer
available and the flight will no longer
be happening damn have you heard about
they just identifi the phone case on the
iPhone that fell out of that flight it
like hit the ground at was the phone
case it's um I should have come prepared
for this comment but apparently this was
like the big thing with all of these
like you know whatever they were like
somebody needs to tell a stat what it is
because it fell from like the sky at 75
miles hour I I I the if I take my phone
with no case and I whip it at the ground
as hard as I can and it hits the ground
yes it's going to be fine I don't know
man this phone landed in a one of the
the phone they found landed in a bush
and a guy was out for a run and he looks
like there it is yeah your phone hits
the tree bounces back and forth it's not
going to break these things are aming
sky Tim the sky teral velocity it was
open there was like no passcode or
anything well it's because the person
was apparently reading their email about
their baggage which is the crazy thing
so when the dude found it and opened it
it opened up to an email saying you know
your baggage fee or whatever Maybe This
sounds too perfect now I'm starting to
get skeptical like could you imagine if
someone could identify what flight it
was on like so you're sitting in the
chair and your phone gets sucked out
yeah imagine you're sitting next to the
the the door with your seat Bel well and
that was the thing the two people that
were supposed to sit there like last
minute decided not to go on this trip
and so the seats were empty like H now
it seems a little
sketchy no that was uh uh they actually
explained that what had happened was the
two people were supposed to sit there
were waiting in the in in the lounge
before the flight and it was a guy and a
woman and the guy fell asleep and then
he woke up in a cold sweat screaming the
plane was going to crash and so he
started yelling and they pulled him off
the planes he's like I got to get out of
here I got to get off this plane they
pulled him out and then uh that happened
and now they're marked by death and um
even though they escaped the
plane sounds is it the plot of Final
Destination Serge over here gets it no
no I don't get it and I believe you 100%
okay well there's like 12 Final
Destination movies 12 of them probably
they're all the same they're all the
same and they're all basically a guy and
a woman go on an airplane plane the guy
the plane crashes and then he wakes up
and goes what did I just witness I had a
vision freaks out they throw him off the
plane the plane crashes and then they go
you cheated death and now death is
coming for you and then like instead of
just having them I don't know like slip
and hit their head in their bathroom
death decides to have some circuitous
Rube Goldberg device you know spin
around 12 times that's bored death needs
something to do I guess I'd like to I'd
like to do my version of like I want to
make short films and mine would be final
destination but like if death was
competent M and it would just be like
the guy goes home walks up his stairs
slips on Ice bashes his face on the
ground and that's it did you ever see
the seventh seal you know that Bergman
film uh so uh death comes for this guy
and the guy's like okay well I'll play a
chess for it and they oh yeah that old
movie yeah it's old movie it's like yeah
70s or something yeah yeah I like that I
like that one better Final Destination
it was really just the one so Final
Destination is a bad concept and then
they made it 12 times seems a bad
concept I think I just think the seventh
seal probably was really good I like
that movie I've been flying a lot lately
and I noticed the the service on these
planes have become really unbearable bad
I don't know if it's a start of the Pete
buz's recruitment of his diversity and
Equity inclusion recruitment but it's
been really really bad no I think it's
cultural breakdown it's everywhere it's
in restaurants and everything too it's
not
just everywhere everywhere so falling to
the floor crazy too plus tipping culture
it's kind of that's out of control right
like I go to Starbucks and then there's
like a tip thing that pops up and it's
like you know 135 tip and I'm like bro I
ordered a $2 coffee and there's I
ordered something online from a store
like a small business and they asked me
to tip and I thought no I don't think
you get St I was at Starbucks when we
were in De Moine and the tip jar said on
a scale of $1 to $10 how attractive are
you and I was like
brilliant but kind of crazy that we're
getting to the point where it's like can
I get a $10 tips sir so I I I went to
this place Anytime Fitness to work out
in the morning as I woke up it was and
there was no workers there just a fob
they trust people to go in with a fob so
I'm like this is great I was going to
pay for a day pass so I worked out there
great little fitness place then I went
to the pizza place next door and just
ordered a salad and the tip popped up
like even at a little pizza place they
got the tip popping up and they've we've
become like almost like a guilty culture
now you feel almost like they're pushing
you to feel guilty that you have to give
a dollar nobody wants to do their job
nobody nobody wants to do the jobs
they're doing I don't know what it is
they want but I will say that Millen the
millennial generation and and large
portions of the younger Generations want
to do literally nothing somebody's got
to do the work and make the food and
what's happening as is you know maybe
it's uh strong men make hard times the
previous generation were like here's my
job this is the job that I do it's the
job I have now it's like oh I have to go
to work today I'm going to have f it and
it used to be a common thing when the
cut when the cashier or the w was nice
now it's like a rarity wow that person
was nice it's like
whoa there's all these things too like
I've been seeing um you know different
you know things online about um job
interviews and it'll be the person being
like so this person came in for a job
interview they wanted to work only four
days a week they wanted to know about
the work life balance it's a starting
position they wanted 150 to start and
it's all of this sort of crazy stuff
like what happened to the thing where
you take a job you want to do well you
want to do well for your personal life
you want to do well professionally and
so you work your ass off you work
overtime you know you come in early you
stay late I've done that with jobs I
hated you know I do that with a job I
love but like I've done that with jobs
that I just don't like and I think to
myself I'm grateful to have a job I'm
grateful I have health insurance you
know I'm going to work hard not to get
fired like somebody else just got fired
it's not going to be me do you think
part of it is that there's no vision for
the future with the Young Generation
I think I think the generation is so
weirdly hopeless and dark they're sort
of like there is no motivation to do
anything right they they don't they
don't aspire to anything greater because
yeah nihilism like it's the same thing
when they talk about climate change and
they're like well I don't want to have
kids because I don't want to burden the
climate with my children and my children
with the climate or whatever like having
more kids makad weather they it doesn't
whatever they feel like they work in
these endless jobs that sort of go
nowhere they feel like they don't create
everything is faceless like they are
sort of numb to everything around them
and so there's actually no momentum
behind their choices like when you talk
about I'm going to work this job really
hard because maybe this isn't where I'm
going to be forever but it's the job I
have right now and it could get me
somewhere else like you you are forward
thing person everybody wants to be the
main character yeah but like be the main
character the main character doesn't
always have $150,000 a year and four
days a
week balance sometimes the main
character just works their ass no the
main character in Shaun of the Dead was
lazy half ass had terrible IDE ideas got
his friends killed and he's still the
main character or like in on reals or
Tik toks they they have these things
that girls talk about like romcom jobs
where they like are uh they it's like
it's like jobs said I will leave for T
no I'm just kidding but they like work
at bookstores and they like know about
books and it's pretty and they have like
tiny studio apartments and there's some
they kind of romanticize it right or
they like are Cafe girls they work in
waitresses and then like eventually they
meet a handsome man and get married like
there are jobs that people kind of can
spin and tell themselves like maybe this
for but there's something kind of maybe
we need a dictator maybe we literally
need a dictator to be like just for day
one no for for for three months because
these people who are like I want a job
like the idea that I get to have a big
house I get to have whatever I want all
the latest devices in all the latest
fashion and I'm going to like friends
for instance I work at a coffee shop and
I live in this massive New York
apartment they explained it eventually
but yeah sure what like an arys what was
the explanation the explanation was it
was Monica's Grandma's apartment and it
was rant controlled and Monica took it
over and the landlord doesn't know that
Monica's Grandma's
dead cuz you can't you can't grandfather
those things in right well so what
happens is grandmother all these young
people expect free stuff and I'm just
like I would love if but for a moment
these people had to survive off of their
own whts and we just dropped them in the
middle of the woods and said good luck
because then they'd be like but where is
my latte in my apartment make it but
someone else should do it for me and we
should tax you and take your money so
that I can live in this beautiful place
the government should pay for my bills
and should cover the cost of my
utilities and someone else should cover
the cost of transportation for me and
then I should be able to you know make a
Chaz Farm remember the Chaz Farm yeah
that was ludicrous and it was filled
with rats and they tried to clear it
just recently they cleared it I had the
same conversation with my son who was
like people should have free healthcare
and I was like really who should pay for
it and he was like the government should
pay for it and I was like hun have have
you heard of taxes and he was like what
and I was like I pay taxes I work really
hard and I pay taxes should I pay taxes
so that other people can have free stuff
that I pay for myself and he was like oh
maybe I should rethink this yeah yeah
think it through people Nothing is free
I've told the story before but uh during
Occupy Wall Street someone gifted like
five or 10 acres of Farmland I think it
was more than I think it might have been
like 20 or something and they said you
know anybody who wants to come and live
here can utilize the land and live off
the land and a bunch of these hippie
dippy college kids were like yeah
I'm going to live carbon neutral and and
just live off the land cuz everybody
knows that peasants had more vacation
time than the modern worker they really
believe that and I always you know how
long did my friend last on this Farm two
weeks that's it two weeks was all was
was all it took and she came back and I
was like weren't you going to go live on
that farm and just live off the land and
she was like I would wake up at 6:00
a.m. and go to bed at 11:00 and I would
work the whole time and I'm like uh-huh
that sounds like my day sounds like
living on a farm she was like yeah but
it was crazy like I don't have time to
read or watch TV or even take a shower
and I'm like right yeah uhhuh yeah it
sounds like living on a farm oh you like
living your petroleum fueled luxury
reality in
America I like why I think people who
are willing to work hard decide that
there is something worth it right like
maybe you're you have a family feed and
you just have to do it it's necessity
but then I think also people who like
what they're doing who are interested
and passionate feel driven and I think
that's the problem the the the Young
Generation coming up is that they feel
nothing they are
ultimately netive we are standing on the
shoulders of giants in terms of the
technology I was crossing the
Williamsburg Bridge one day and I just
thought to myself how amazing that so
many people came together to build this
thing so that I can leisurely walk
across this River where normally it was
rather difficult and that was just it's
just there mhm I don't pay for it
there's three River CR Crossings
downtown it's really really amazing but
now we have so many people who don't
know what it took to build that and I'm
going to add one more to that we're not
just standing on the shoulders of giants
who have lived in the days of yor we are
standing on the shoulders of slaves in
foreign countries and third world
countries who are mining coal balt and
other rare earth metals and their teeth
are rotting out of their faces and we
don't see it at all so when when these
activists are like we should get rid of
fossil fuels and all that stuff like
well you're the first to die like you
know when Greta tunberg like we're not
going to V till 2030 we must stop now
I'm like that chick would be dead in 3
days but the other thing too is you have
Joe Biden pushing for all of the solar
and pushing for EVS and lithium battery
fueled things and that's literally just
yeah that's actually pretty funny the
car yeah the dead robots the car grave
everywhere but also we're we're saying
like you know instead of using fuel from
America or fuel you know fossil fuels
we're just going to have kids do the
mining and we're going to use their
labor but that's the Joe Biden thing and
there are people who are like we can
automate this mining no you can't maybe
eventually we can get to this point but
humans especially you know children they
got those little fingers that are good
for digging around in tight spaces and
so in these foreign countries what
Google search the videos of the Cobalt
mines I mean this is big news where you
have just like 10,000 people all just
sifting through the mud and dirt to find
this stuff and that's what is that this
is how you live in luxury but we're
gonna go to super chats but I guess
because a lot of by by popular demand
everyone is demanding uh brim cast
uncensored no way so fun I I guess so so
instead of hope you guys both want to
stay and Tim's gonna go to bed well yeah
no it's well earned that's not me being
mean to Tim that's that's saying please
also stay so it's not just me talking to
the camera but we'll go to Super Chat no
way to go off thing good I love hostage
guests smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and head over to
timcast.net us to become a member and at
10 p.m. on the front page we will have
the first official uncensored brim cast
IRL uh normally we do the members only
uncensored show at 10 p.m. but uh
because I'm operating on about 3 to four
hours of sleep I am uh it's actually
pain I'm feeling all over my body from
lack of sleep once we wrap the super
chats I'm going to bed but Hannah clir
will will run the members only taking
calls from you in the members only
Discord where you can talk to us and our
guests not me though I won't be here
just like I planned I made it snow for
this I said here's an opportunity yeah
I'm just K was so brutal like when
driving from the airport we landed in
hagertown and uh there's 4 Ines of just
perfect fluffy snow and no plows we're
in the middle of nowhere and uh the
vehicles we have we got a couple SUVs
and a Honda Civic we had to drive 20 30
m hour the whole way back slowly sliding
because there's no plows and salt in the
back Country Roads or anything like this
so oh man it took so long I get really
impatient with that like I grew up in
New England so grew up with snow things
like that but then when you're driving
and the condition is just such that you
cannot speed up and there's no plow and
you just have to go slow I start to just
like get the Jitters like I'm like maybe
it's worth speeding and flying off the
road yeah but then once we finally got
back to the
house going up the driveway 10 ft and
then slid back down and it's like but
we're going to read super chats Raymond
g Stanley Jr says moral compass doesn't
Point North a dream of her is to bomb
the Earth absolute bird brain batish
crazy everyone meet no teeth moving
Nikki
Haley maniple has the first Super Chat
saying foist that is correct sir you've
won the
prize all right I hope they keep score
on the Discord of who actually gets like
the most amount of Firsts in a month and
then they chatter of the maybe we can do
something like that I wonder what the
legality is of uh doing a contest where
it's like we will track every day the
first Super Chat and then whoever has
the most at the end of the month gets a
gift yeah or like I don't know 10 grand
or something okay wow a really nice gift
and suddenly a bunch of people are
jumping in the chat I think that that
would qualify does that count as sudden
your subcriptions went up big time it's
10 grand sub CR to our Teespring the
reason why I say I wonder if that the
legality because it sounds like a
lottery almost cuz everyone's going to
be paying two bucks to try and get it
and then but we're not saying it's a
random chance it's you have to be first
but that's a sweep Stakes like if you
call in this number and you there have
to be free ways to join sweep Stakes I
think aren't there isn't that a thing
yeah I
think you had to like have a free way to
yeah so here's the other thing too
because we were planning on doing like
this timcast grant thing where every
month we'd give 10 grand we just can't
do it yeah and so I have given people
money in in through other ways but you
know basically the legality of it is we
want it to be like if you're a member
and you're working on a cool project and
you share with us we will help you you
fund that project it's not legal you're
not allowed to do it you can't weird you
uh because if you require someone to be
a member with a chance to win money you
are engaged in illegal gambling yeah
it's a gambling and I'm like yeah
there's a judging criteria and they're
like the way you do it is you don't have
to be a member and an external panel
decides who gets the money and then I'm
like yeah but we're trying to do this
for the community to invest in this
stuff so basically someone who's never
supported the show doesn't really watch
pitches something we can't ask them if
they're a fan of the show and they any
of the work we do they get the money and
then someone who's worked really really
hard and has been dedicated I'm like so
we really can't do it yeah unfortunately
so we can't do any stuff like that
anyway Jacob Bar says the never Nicki
message needs to be pushed with every
ounce of energy we have Nikki is a
candidate for the Democrats because they
have no one what if something happens
with Trump court cases and is
disqualified Nikki that's right or maybe
Ronda
santis I gotta be honest I'll take Ron
yo if Trump gets knocked out and it's
Ron versus Nikki Ron's got my vote and
and it's and you know what's really
funny is because I was saying before
like I wouldn't vote for him or the over
the AI image debacle then Nikki Haley
jumped in and I was like Lord help us
I've I've I've realized my mistake it
could get
worse a good lesson for for all of us to
learn but maybe that's the real plan
they were like look Ron's not popular we
need to make him look more attractive by
Rel relative comparison it's Ron's
backers who were like Micki come on join
the race they're like we need Ron to
look better you know this super long
primary season we live in it's never
ending at least it really hyperfocused
on their personalities and they couldn't
you couldn't get around it right so
you're really shined on who really Nikki
is and who Ron is and it's part of our
culture now it's just never wish we
didn't live in this
NeverEnding cycle of running for since
since 2015 it's never ended yep never
that's crazy so crazy people make money
I feel like I feel like it was just
January 6 yesterday I remember when uh
we started timcast IRL like don't forget
January
some of the first some of the first
Clips we did was like reviewing Sonic
the Hedgehog and talking about aliens
and then just politics became pop
culture every every day it got crazier
and crazier and has been ever since and
uh you know the funny thing is so I have
youtube.com/ timcast that's where the
culture War show uh Clips go up every
day and then the live show itself is on
tenant media so guys subscribe to them
they're they're awesome doing really
great work and uh that was like that
channel I would do a 4 pm News segment
that was about a half an hour long and
I'd be like here's the big story of the
day and then I have youtube.com/ timcast
news subscribe to that channel as well
where I put up four videos every day
that channel was like movies video games
commentary culture pop culture stuff and
all of that just turned into politics
nobody cares about any of that stuff
anymore and so now that channel is just
basically like the news and what's going
on and man it's kind it's kind of wild
that this is where we we've gotten to
culturally it's just politics is pop
culture everything is politics all the
time I mean meia Khalifa being
confronted by like some Jewish mother
I'm like why is the porn star lady
debating is real yes what the why it's
too much well I have a I have a good
friend before I went on the air name
Mike phame and he's a big online
marketer Tech guy and he says tell Tim
thank Tim because we were all afraid
five years ago to come out so afraid now
because of Tim and these other podcasts
across the country we we're we're ready
to speak so he wanted to thank you for
that I appreciate it there was a really
funny Post in like 2017 where uh someone
wrote about coming out as a trump
supporter and a bunch of people were
commenting that they were like identical
to coming out as gay it was like I'm I'm
scared to tell my family and friends
that that I support Donald Trump because
they'll they'll shut me and osiz me they
won't accept me or they may kick me out
of the family and I was like this is so
funny I think that is the experience
though and in some ways because
everything has become so political I
almost almost wonder if we'll get a
moment where everyone's like burned out
of politics and it becomes uninteresting
I just think we have another four or
five years to go unfortunately yeah I
feel a lot of people that have been
saying that they just burned out on it
in general all right Joe spell says is a
comment to your earlier segment people
in Alaska plugging in their vehicles
those are heater blocks especially for
diesel not primarily for the battery
diesel fuel in subarctic temperatures
can turn to jelly that's that's correct
but your earlier comment is incorrect
every vehicle had a plug in it and
they're gas vehicles not diesel vehicles
and it was for their batteries be at
least that's what they told us the car
rental agency said your gasoline SUV
will freeze the battery will stop
working you have to plug it in in fact
when they gave us the car the remote the
uh uh uh the electronic entry didn't
work there oh I got to tell you we got
an SUV they're they they give us the key
to it it's minus 28 it doesn't work and
so we're out there it's freezing in Iowa
Alaska we're in Fairbanks and uh they
said yeah if it doesn't work just pop
the key out because there is a
mechanical key in it the the the the the
car has no Keyhole anymore they're all
electric remote entry and it's too cold
so it doesn't work and so they're like
oh you're going have to warm it up and
I'm yeah so it was plugged in all the
rentals come with extension cables and
they say if you don't plug it in your
battery will die so that's what they
told us that's crazy I do understand
that diesel also has heater blocks
because diesel needs to get warmed up
before it can start sure I get that but
plugging in the vehicles was
specifically because the batteries were
dying you know and we went to the hotel
and they didn't have any plugs all the
and so we went in and said it's minus 28
right now will the car be fine overnight
and the lady said no your battery will
be dead in the morning and we're like
okay and she's like so go drive around
until you can find a place to plug it in
if you can't park in a handicap and then
we waited someone left we took a spot we
plugged it in but uh that's what we were
told maybe they were wrong I don't
know all right
Sly Hooper says Encanto is the last good
Disney movie worth the watch I don't
believe it I'm not watching it sorry I
never saw it I'm not going to do it I'm
okay yeah so She-Hulk I guess that's you
know she shehulk got canceled or
whatever good that show was weird I only
saw one episode of it it won't go broke
my son and his friend hate watched that
show what was their take they would tell
me about it they hated it they just
thought that it was really lame and that
the main character had absolutely no
story arc yeah and then the story arc
doesn't even like what what Arc there
was is her just jumping out of the
Disney plus I'm not kidding she jumps
out of the Disney plus I thumbnail for
the show and then walks around the
Disney plus streaming app and like then
meets Kevin feige or something man they
really had no idea what they were doing
they lost their minds all right the
homeless veteran says how do I get on
here to tell my story about an insane
paranormal Mission I had overseas that
is still not acknowledged retired army
and about my persecution by the FBI and
USG I want to tell it ID GF about after
um that sounds like a job for Shane
Cashman MH so uh normal stuff is
definitely Shane yeah the inverted world
live show is going to be getting started
uh very soon because um we finally got
the freedan building done but it's not
just freedan the uh the new studio
location we have is 50 acres it's got
multiple structures we've got two
primary offices and Studios for the show
so we're going to be so we can launch
more shows really really crazy what
we're building over here we're investing
Millions into our new skate show the
boonies so subscribe to the boonies I
think it's Boonies HQ on YouTube Just
you can search for the boonies and
Instagram where we're going to be
building uh we've already built this
large private facility the skat Park
should be done in about April a bunch of
pro skateboarders have already come
through and done interviews with pro
skateboarder Richie Jackson who is our
principal host of The Boonies show and
we've got big interest from some of the
top Pros in the world I got to tell you
guys have hope do not be blackpilled
when I watch these uh uh huge Pros for
like Nitro Circus and I'm talking like
big professional athletes and they're
wearing Public Square t-shirts Black
Rifle coffee we are winning it used to
be that these Pro skaters i' complain
about they'd hit me up being like look
man I'm a big fan but I'm scared I'll
get fired for my job now they're like
well if I do get dropped I mean Black
Rifle called me up they're offering
sponsorships I'm like yes so you know as
much as people have had beef with Black
Rifle in the past yo they're sponsoring
athletes and giving them a chance to say
f you to the W garbage that is awesome
yeah I know people have a lot of
opinions about black rivel coffee but
every time I I'm in at Walmart and I see
how much Black Rifle coffee is there it
kind of blows my mind because I remember
when they were just sponsoring people on
YouTube I I didn't even know if they had
a retail store and now it's like oh
you're you're pushing your way into the
main stream when when I heard that uh I
don't know if I'm breaking I don't think
I'm breaking it but Travis Pastrana is
uh sponsored by uh Black Rifle I'm
pretty sure that's true right let me
just uh let me double check here yeah
Travis Pastrana is uh sponsored by Black
Rifle coffee I
believe whatever and uh when I found out
that was happening back in the day cuz
he was on Red Bull before I was like
we're winning and this is this is
massive this is this is a pro TOA
company far from perfect lot of people
have their criticisms but there's
there's other pro skateboarders wearing
Public Square shirts and I'm and pro
athletes and I'm like we are winning
some of the biggest pro skateboarders in
the world in their skat Parks have
rumble on their on their on their walls
and Rumble is the uh uh uh I I believe
is the exclusive uh location for Street
League Skateboarding I'm like guys we're
winning this now I'm getting hit up by
some of the biggest names in
professional sports in action sports
saying like we're huge fans we're going
to come out we're going to skate scoot
blade bike all that stuff and I'm like
this is it young people are going to be
pulled in this direction we're going to
believe in Freedom meritocracy
individual responsibility this how we do
it good fun I just wanted to say with
regard to Disney did you guys see the
new thing that they came up with which
was a um uh the first deaf Native
American ampute superhero Echo yeah yeah
but I don't I don't really have I don't
have an issue with it so much as they're
making it about that because imagine if
Daredevil was like the first blind
superhero and the whole show was just
about how he's being oppressed for being
differently abled so when they're like
we're making a show about a minority
deaf woman I'm like no no no hold on
hold
on we like Daredevil okay he was a kid
he got blinded so he attuned his his
senses so now he has like super senses
and he became super great blindness does
not make him it actually makes the
character really interesting like in the
scene in Spider-Man when he's sitting at
the table and the brick flies through
the window and he catches it and they're
like how did you do that and he's like
I'm a really good lawyer like it's great
because a blind person should not be so
good at this but he's a superhero so if
they're going to make Ekko who's deaf it
needs to be like look Daredevil is blind
and he has echol location because his
ears are so good but it's also his
weakness loud noises go ah and he falls
what are they doing with eeko she is a
minority ampute deaf woman and then they
do a bunch of cringe stuff in the
trailer that are it's about being deaf
and it's like H come on man that's the
lame part is when you make it about the
thing as opposed to about a story or a
narrative or something organic the only
place that's worked is um a quiet place
right where like the daughter was deaf
but it worked out in this world gave
this family this Advantage they already
spoke sign language like that's when I
felt like that played into to the
storyline well big champ says BOS s Tim
and friends I'd like to recommend
Youngstown Ohio for your live show being
the halfway point between Pittsburgh and
Cleveland you'd be sure to draw a good
crowd penguin City brewery as a possible
venue isn't uh I'm pretty sure
Youngstown is where during the Occupy
protests the like the police and
firefighters joined in the protests over
the the corruption in government and
then the government went to the police
and said we'll give you anything you
want the cop said you got it turned
around and arrest all their co-s wow I'm
I'm I'm exaggerating like that's
medieval the cops got what they wanted
and turned around said okay everybody
time to go home reminds me of I think it
was Family Guy Peter Griffin's
protesting the new Supermarket that the
Super Center that moves in like it's
Walmart or whatever and then when he
goes into complain that from a job then
he turns around walks out and says you
are trespassing and you are required to
leave that's the reality of a lot of
people man they'll sit there and scream
and protest all you got to do is offer
them cash and then all of a sudden
they're like I'm with you this is true
for a lot of these leftists I make a
wager maybe we can do an undercover show
to prove this point really destroy some
of these woke far-left extremists
undercover footage where you go to some
far-left antifa person and then just
legitimately offer them cash to do a job
that they would otherwise protest and
when they say yes then be like oh hey
look here's this guy you think is a big
Eco activist and environmentalist we
offered him you know a six-figure job
working on a petroleum rig and he said
yes well you know it's because I thought
I could do more good yeah okay please
dude but also work I just feel like
that's the thing that they're going to
be averse to yeah you could be like hey
you've got a bu of followers on social
media we'd be willing to pay you you
know like hey we we agree we're trying
to sa the environment but help us do the
right thing and spread the good word
about the good work we're doing and why
petroleum is good and we'll pay you 20
grand and they're going to be like okay
there were a bunch of um or I saw this
report that gas stations were trying to
give sponsorships to lots of like young
social media influencers be like come to
my gas station it is cool I thought was
kind of funny gas stations are always
cool yeah but the fact that you have to
pay an influencer to tell you that
that's weird Wyatt calenberg says HCB do
the after show you are smart and well
read you and Libby can do it three cins
in small talk it's time to move your
game up a level dude thanks this is
career coaching from the chat over here
what a hype you guys are fun and then
Christopher Lambert says brim cast brim
cast brim cast brim cast I'm not putting
the energy into it I'm tired but there's
like 15 exclamation points there well I
appreciate this oh my gosh uh Serge
texted me I will say during the Shing
like so are you being serious about this
and I was like it's yours and it's Tim's
idea that I do the after show so I'm
glad the chats and support I'm I'm happy
to do it that's the point of having
other people work at this company it's
just the after show but it keeps the so
I can't ruin it I mean it's it's behind
the no it's like it you know it's it's
it's an opportunity for the guests to
call in and ask
questions members I really like our
members I did um over Thanksgiving
Rayman G sty Jr like walked me through
how to use our Discord cuz I'm a boomer
and I got to talk to people in the
Discord and they're like it's such a
cool Community I'm glad that we' have
been able to cultivate it somehow or at
least bring them together in a central
place so the event we did in Iowa I
think we're going to end up losing you
know low five figures on doing that trip
because it costs like it cost over
$100,000 to do wow in order to get nine
people because we have people who
produce the show uh manage the
venues work with guest relations and
stuff and security the only way to do it
is if we fly out on a private jet only
way to make it possible and I'm not some
hippie dippy Eco activist I don't care
if you're flying a private jet as long
as you can afford it but uh if you're a
hypocrite then you'll make fun of you so
you know it's like so last week on
Tuesday as soon as the Show wrapped at
you know 11: we got out the door got in
the car drove straight to the jet landed
in in in Iowa like 2 in the morning went
to bed and woke up to start producing uh
oh no no I'm sorry I'm sorry that's not
what happened the flag got canceled
because of the weather did the morning
show and then left that morning landed
and then did did the nightly show then
coming back it was also extremely brutal
we did we were sponsored by based
records B records uh super uh grateful
for their help excited to work with them
on some music projects too and uh that
helped cover a bulk of the costs but not
all of it we sold tickets the ticket
sales cover almost nothing and so uh we
lose money doing it but I think it's
incredibly beneficial to the company and
I think it's incredibly beneficial
culturally to have these on location
events where people can come and hang
out and actually watch the show in
person ask questions but one of the
plans I think we're going to to do we've
been advised by some bigger companies is
and uh this is Luke's idea is to do
super private uh like VIP dinners
between five and $10,000 per ticket not
for individual regular people but for
businesses who wanted to have private
meetings and it's not because we want to
make money it's because we want to fund
the show so it's like if we want to if
we want to do more events here's the
Restriction we reach out to sponsors and
say hey guys we want to do a stage show
in this place it's going to cost here's
all the cost will show all of them to
you Stage production camera equipment
rental security and people don't
understand how expensive security is
seriously if you've got a presidential
candidate coming down they're going to
be like seven how many exits in the
build how many exit entrances in the
building eight I want two guards at each
entrance okay those are 50 bucks an hour
people and so all that's super expensive
per day but this way we can actually put
it out there and be like if we can't get
a sponsor we'll try that approach
because we've actually had people say
straight up they would like we've had
people be like hey I will I will give
you x amount of dollars to just be able
to come and do like a private meeting
with you guys and we're like why don't
we do a dinner and so I think that's one
one opportunity to help fund more of
these things because uh we've got people
who want us to do you know once a month
or something and I'm like bro that is so
brutal like people don't sleep got to
get on a plane the only way that's
possible is with a lot of money and then
everyone says okay and we're like okay
well then you help fund it and they're
like okay and I'm like all right well
we'll give it a shot we'll see what
happens so that's one idea we might do
and uh you know we'll see what happens
but uh I think the next event we'll have
a series of like Ultra VIP private
dinner tickets which it's basically what
politicians do when they're like hey
it's you know five grand for a ticket to
come have dinner with me but ours is
going to be like you come have dinner
then we go to the show and you help put
that show on and we'll give you a shout
out and thank you for sponsoring the
show or they Trump does a fundraise he
charges for clicks photos really
beforehand yeah just to get a photo 25k
something like that 25k for a photo with
Trump and then and then afterwards is
the regular fundraiser for maybe ,000 I
get it I mean if you're doing a
fundraiser and you're like look like
Trump's you get a photo with the sitting
President right yeah and my thing is
like my first thought is man to try and
charge that much but there are people
who are like look I run a big company we
want to pitch some ideas to you we would
help it's it's basically not that you're
giving us money for profit it's your
sponsor you're a sponsor so these are
like you get to have private dinner and
then you're also a listed sponsor of of
the show at the time and stuff like that
so I think it'll be fun and that's what
we'll we'll try to do so that'll help us
get uh more events and allows to travel
to more places all right the real ra
kamacho Ro kamacho says magas Swami the
VP make it happen he would be good he
would be good I don't know who would be
better to be completely honest I know
who politically and market-wise could be
good but V is uh man V is a good weapon
for Donald Trump you cannot win an
argument with that man like the me the
media will try to go after him he's
going to run circles around him fair
very very smart guy very smart and very
articulate right what did Joe Biden say
about Barack Obama do you remember that
no no what do Joe Biden said something
about Barack Obama was articulate
articulate yeah something like that
would this guy is our president and he
was his vice president how he didn't say
it like that what he said something
something but it probably was basically
like that I mean somebody must bring in
this golden retriever immediately
actually if Trump said take over my
press conference today it would be
amazing right cuz vka is incredible hand
in the Press he did almost just as good
as almost as good as Trump yeah in7 I
mean you got the first mainstream
African-American who is articulate and
bright and clean and a nice looking guy
dude Biden's a but the Maga extremists
are racist like this is what he said I
mean that's a story book
man geez oh man all right classic uh
classic Stang lover says doesn't cabinet
members have to be pre-approve be
approved by Congress would they allow a
vake I don't think they have to be
approved right cabinet members no that's
just like you hiring your staff I think
so there's certain positions that have
to be approved confirmation and but
those are like bureaucratic positions
M all right get a pair with Sully says
Tim Dems infiltrating Republicans the
same as what the wigs did when they went
extinct the wigs took over the Democrats
completely and remained prominent in
reps the first rep Republican president
was a lifelong wig yes Lincoln was a wig
huh you don't be really funny if
Republicans infiltrate the Democratic
primary and then nominate Trump and then
Nikki Haley wins the Republican but
Trump's the Democrat and everyone's just
like I guess I'm voting Democrat I don't
never thought that would happen then
Donald Trump is like I'm changing
parties now that I'm
elected all right BT Diaz says the
cabinet positions etc for aake is all
good is good and all but how much
government experience did Trump have in
2016 I reject this notion that
government experience small time or
otherwise guarantees a good president I
didn't say that I said Donald Trump has
experience in government so he'd be
better than V ramaswami ramaswami
getting experience in government would
make him a better president in 2028 and
you said that and it keeps and it keeps
him in the news constantly he needs to
be in the news he needs to be and you
know the news is not going to get any
nicer to Trump and we need a fighter
like VC going against the news cycle
going against the mainstream media
constantly because we we're going to get
a a barrage of anti-trump anti
conservative sorry I'm jumping out of my
skin tonight I'm so nervous about brim
cast um no and and what Tim said from
what I remember about it was that one of
the things Trump had to do during his
first time in office was to learn where
there were issues and learn where the
landmines are I mean having experience
being able to see what's going on on the
inside would benefit V or whoever is the
nominee in 2028 jod Den 80 says if Trump
picks Tulsa for VP doesn't that boost
his chances of getting on Rogan does
that boost her chances dude a Rogan
gabard Trump episode would be the most
viewed podcast in history yeah probably
that would be cool like if if Trump went
on Rogan it would get a lot of views and
it may be close to the most viewed
podcast in history but like you throw
someone in the mix like tulsy gabard or
even vake and it's going to be the most
like who's gonna miss that show yeah no
way yeah for
sure all right let's grab one more here
what do we
have all right Jason Hutchinson says Tim
buy a jet and when they and when are not
flying you around rent it out that is an
option and jets aren't as expensive as
people think I shouldn't say Jets but uh
private private flight so we need look
at this there are like five-seater turbo
prop planes that are a couple hundred
grand so that means you're spending like
two or $3,000 a month on on the uh on
the loan then you've got to have
Staffing that could be like 100 to 200k
for for a good pilot and you probably
need more than one so all in all we
talked to a company and we were like if
we want to do
every month some kind of event that
means we need a jet and they said
ultimately you're going to end up
spending like a million bucks a year to
maintain Fuel and fly this thing and
you've got to make it worth it and I'm
like oh man that's kind of crazy if we
if we do like four events per year we're
going to be spending like a hundred
grand per year in private flights and so
okay maybe maybe that's you know we do
something smaller but uh there's
something called Net Jets where you
spend several hundred thousand to buy a
share shares in a Fleet and then when
you schedule a flight all you have to do
is pay the the the time for the staff
you pay the flat costs so there's no
profit you know like when you when you
when you book a private jet there's a
broker fee they will someone someone's
renting the plane out they want to make
a profit with netjets it's just covering
the costs and you're a part owner and
you can always sell your shares later
it's like a time share for jets yeah and
it's what a lot I think it's what
whenever I talk to ultra rich people
they most of them don't even bother
having jets that I talk to but I mean if
you're super rich like Bill Gates
probably got five Trump's got three I
think but for like the not Ultra
billionaires it's just it makes more
sense I know a guy who's like
effectively a billionaire and he's like
and Nets is easier they handle
everything for it you don't got to worry
about Pilots you don't got to manage
anything you just call them up and say
Here's the flight I need and they say we
we'll see you there is it ever funny to
you that you have reached a place in
your life where people are like Tim just
buy a private plane just buy a private
plane Tim I always knew this day would
come okay so you did no not really I
mean it's it's when when we're at this
point where we flew on a private jet
last this morning we were landing and
it's funny I'm thinking about it how
it's not fun was it netjets did you Jets
it was a broker it was a regular broker
uh the the first planing we got out
there was great it had a Wi-Fi on it the
flight back didn't you know you never
know what you're going to get cuz you
just basically what we do is we call
broker and we said we need a flight and
say here's what we can find for you and
you got to pay these ridiculous fees and
it's massive and it's expensive but for
me it's just like it is not fun to land
at 3: in the morning and then not get
any sleep no that doesn't sound fun at
all so these people make these videos
and Instagram posts where they're like
walk down to a private jet and I'm like
dude the average person who's flying is
bored of flying and is like I've got to
travel for a meeting it's work it's work
it's work and it's just a pract it's a
it's a practical issue of is there is
there business and market demand for
what you're doing and if there is then
you have to spend the money on it and I
don't walk out of the airport and go wow
at me on a private jet and I'm like uh
yeah espe we got we got to rush out the
door it's stressful it's it's painful
it's it's it's uncomfortable there's no
food you do not like the ba if you if
you're lucky enough to get one of these
things with the bathroom because most of
them don't have like a lot of jets and
turbo props they have no bathrooms no
bathroom yeah you're flying you're
flying for a couple hours no bathroom
they say go before you leave and good
luck the nicer ones will have a bathroom
but the bathrooms are really awful and
you're cramped it's not fun flying first
class commercial is better when way
better they give you a steak you get a
wet wet claw a mo hot towel and you're
wiping your face but then you got to go
through security and deal all the BS and
so in the long run it's like I can't go
to IAD to fly at midnight to catch you
know a show in Iowa and do this stuff so
that's where we're at but uh we'll wrap
it up there if uh uh become a member at
timcast.net I've had a headache the
whole time because I haven't slept but
uh you know I I just you got to do what
you got to do so I appreciate all of you
guys watching and supporting the show
making all this possible uh I shouted
out Bas record several times because we
were only able to do the Iowa show with
with their help because they they
sponsored the show it didn't cover all
the costs you guys as member members
made it possible and picked up the rest
so shout out to all of the
timcast.net Adam do you want to shout
anything out uh thanks for having me Tim
and uh we have some great uh I got some
great spots to tell you for your tour
and uh hopefully we'll see you in New
York New York and Miami again yeah I
think uh Miami's absolutely yes uh New
York will probably be like outside New
York somewhere you know Long Island
maybe yeah maybe outside of New York
State you know maybe we'll we'll figure
it out but uh yeah thanks for hanging
out are you on social media people
follow you on Adam Matthew is my Twitter
handle Adam PR is my Instagram cool what
about like Niagara Falls yeah yes let's
go to Niagara Falls that sounds fun
Pittsburgh's out of the question that is
heartbreaking to me I'm so sad about it
there uh without naming any of these
venues the general idea as conveyed to
me is they're all basically like if we
book you anti will burn down the venue
damn come on Pittsburgh I no not
clarifying I don't believe anyone has
explosively said anything like that but
they're scared is the vi is as I'm
described it seems like I'm being very
careful uh their concern is that anti
will burn down their venues if we if
they host us I still wish we could do a
show somewhere in Pennsylvania because I
think it's just such an interesting time
to be in Pennsylvania but Harris we may
have a big West Virginia one coming up
good I love WG great also a good place
not far away okay yeah which is one of
the benefits for Pittsburgh R but yeah
uh well that's too bad but hopefully our
Pittsburgh based friends could come on
down to West Virginia uh I'm Hannah CL
rmo a writer for cnr.com and I am the
host of the one time only after show
called brim cast uh I hope you guys will
come over there tonight and hang out uh
you should follow timcast newws on
Instagram and Twitter to see all of
scanner news's work that's sr.com if you
want to follow me personally I'm on uh
Twitter at hcbo and I'm on Instagram at
hanac clare. guys thank you so much uh
and maybe I'll see you later liby I was
so glad to see you tonight yeah it's
great to see you too I'm Libby Emmons
I'm the editor for the post millennial
and human events you can find me on
Twitter at liby ens you can check out
all the great work we're doing at the
postm
millennial.age you can find me pretty
much anywhere on the internet at s g d o
tcom spell it out I'm going to get that
URL soon uh yeah we excited for this
brim cast all right everybody head over
to
timcast.net and you can watch brim cast
uncensored the first ever official
episode coming up in a few minutes and I
will be sleeping and uh I will have yyu
Haku Show on in the background thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all
then